the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the third leg of the grand chess tour is
underway at the super united rapid and
blitz in zagreb croatia
the very best in the world are ready to
showcase their rapid and blitz prowess
for their adoring fans french phenom
malareza farouza is the clear leader
winning two of his games and drawing the
other with a four-way tie for second he
will hope to build on his early lead but
the story of the day was reigning world
champion magnus carlson's return to the
tour in the breaking news that he will
not defend his world title leaving the
chess world buzzing what excitement will
today's rounds bring
day two of rapid chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome to round two of the grand chess
tour where the most romantic part of the
city center in zagreb and romantic chess
is what we expect from our players in
the rapids to call all of today's action
let's go to the studio with christian
miro and yasser
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022 grand chess tour
the one in sagrada croatia what a day we
had yesterday we are in day two and
we're here in saint louis to call all of
the action about the zagreb event hello
everyone i'm yasser miro
it was a lot of fun yesterday we had a
remarkable day your thoughts on uh one
yeah my first thought is that i picked
the wrong player to say yeah that those
guys made me made me pick the player
apparently it was a wrong pick but
overall of course a lot of exciting
chess
behind and i believe more in front of us
and one very very
i don't know big statement from the
world champion exactly it was in fact a
stunning announcement on international
chess day as magnus carlson abdicated
his throne as the world champion saying
he's not going to compete in the world
championship match but yes he's going to
compete a lot in the chess world but
after day one three rounds let's go to
the standings uh nero do the honors
please who's on top yeah on top we have
reza firuja the youngest player who
could as well could have been on 100
score but anyway five out of six very
impressive then tied for the second is
magnus carlsen himself wesley saw maxine
vicious and surprisingly jordan van
forest another young gun in this
tournament i'm seeing a lot of decisive
results here how many decisive games did
we have in our day one count
more than a half and after after that
they say chess is a draw exactly well uh
tell us about the format
yeah format is pretty standard for those
rapid and blitz events so 10 planes
around robin
rapid games takes us 25 minutes plus 10
seconds for each player
then blitz which we'll have over
weekends is five minutes plus two
seconds
no draw offers rapid games counts twice
as many points as the blitz games and
that's about it for the four months i
had their schedule
uh well three rounds are played each day
in rapid so it's today we're gonna have
from four to six right yeah three last
rounds tomorrow and then on saturday and
sunday there will be two round robin
blitzes wonderful playoffs if necessary
on a sunday and we're very fortunate as
always to have christian
hi my friend good to see you who are
today's gladiators
good morning guys always a pleasure to
see you always a pleasure to be here in
the studio with you guys casting the
games of the best chess players on the
planet that we have here at the grand
chess tour and what a day filled with
excitement yesterday was but let's take
a look at the standings and uh which
players impressed me the most and i have
to go with the young guns that is ali
reza firuja and jordan van forest i have
to say jordan van furry started blazing
hud with two victories alireza as well
could have easily been on a perfect
score if he wouldn't have missed his
opportunity against yon nepomnyashian
chess is a young person's game for short
only 19 years of age for ali reza 23 for
van forest and let's take a look at
their illustrious careers as well and
where they stand well he's 19 years of
age very very young urs rating 2773 he
is a full grand chess tour participant
we've seen him in romania as well
unfortunately for him he didn't play as
well and he will definitely
be looking for a rebound in this
tournament 2021 feed a grand swiss
winner as well that is the tournament
that qualified him to the candidates he
is also the youngest ever
2800 feeder rated player in the world
beating magnus record well that's just
simply impressive and i remember that
performance at the european team
championship that propulsed him into the
stratosphere at 2 800 and let's take a
look at van forest as well well this
young dutch man is just simply
impressive and already what a career
he's had 23 years of age 26 68 he is
hailing from the netherlands and he is
the 2016 dash champion he also won the
tata still as well as being a second for
magnus carlsen in preparation for his
world championship match against jana
pomiyashi just two very impressive young
guns that we have and we also have our
friends in croatia
what's the atmosphere there guys
thank you christian and welcome everyone
to zagreb we are your on
person in person
i'm grandmaster 100 meters here with
woman grandmaster anastasia carlovich
we have such a yesterday as you guys
mentioned alireza played this tournament
so far but that's not what people were
talking about yesterday yeah they were
talking mostly about magnus carlsen who
decided not to play in the world
championships match world championship
match anymore
so we made dinner yesterday yes
alejandra you managed to catch him we
had a moment to catch with the world
champion let's see what he had to say
you're not defending your world title
does it feel
lighter how do you feel no it's okay i
mean i've been in this mindset now for
uh for over a year so obviously it's uh
um
you know
when it's when it's official it feels
feels a bit weird but i'm i'm fine with
that i'll um continue to to play a bunch
and then
try and uh yeah just do as well as i can
tell us a little bit how what this means
to you as a player will you be as
competitive are you still trying to get
to new heights or are you slowing down a
bit
no i mean i think for a few years now i
haven't been as competitive as
i as i used to be but i still want to
play chess and i still want to do
do well
it just
i'm i mean i don't
i'm perhaps not quite as yeah
i don't have the the same
[Music]
the same quite the same drive but that's
that doesn't mean i'm gonna play a lot
worse
the world champion seemed
cool calm collected he seemed happy but
you've been to all his world
championships and you think he was a bit
emotional yes i think he was emotional
actually yesterday
and also the fact that christina's
photos from the previous world
championship matches perhaps shows that
he was actually not in the best mood and
he said to you that it feels weird um
today he's going to play with eliasa
ferruga in the first round of the second
day and how the game will will be and
actually i think calires is the one who
is a weak or the one to blame that
magnus is not playing in the world
championship matches
i agree we remember that magnus
mentioned that he will be motivated to
play a new generation but that didn't
come to pass aloe didn't do so well in
the candidates and now we're gonna have
a new world champion in 2023 but before
that we have tons of chess three rapid
games ahead of us and as you mentioned a
headliner to start the day guys let's go
back to the studio let's call all of the
action thank you anastasia thank you
alejandro and indeed miro please lay the
table for our audience and tell them
what we can expect in round four of the
rapids
what did we heard from zagreb carson is
motivated to play perugia here you have
it sir yes in round four magnus carson
will have the white pieces against ali
reza firoud rasa feroza is the first
magnus tight for the second right the
other players are mvl is playing one
forest another two players yeah fight
for the second suraj faces wesley saw
and so is the last of those tied for the
second right nepal faces dominguez and
topalov who's yet to score his first
point in zagreb is facing mummy jared
very young for rouge looking very
relaxed he's coming with different
shirts yesterday with the nba the style
is very similar though
yeah i love this uh i think it's a nike
shirt i don't wanna brand it
we we we're gonna have to speculate but
uh they've obviously been fighting very
hard uh what are they fighting for uh
miranda they're fighting for tons of
money yesterday first prize is forty
thousand dollars second one being thirty
third twenty five and so on and so forth
lovely and there you see also the grand
chess door points the player who leads
or wins the grand chess tour there's a
very nice
pool of money as well if you win clear
first mirror 13 points a tie gets you a
playoff and then you're going to
uh the grand chess tour points and as we
get started for this round four i
thought you had that oh that's a
beautiful stage by the way yeah that's
really fling it really looks nice
uh
there's the world champion uh ronnie
is he is he running late
and this is the matchup
that uh magnus
said he wanted uh
for the world championship fallujah did
not perform very well in fact we know
that nepo was the challenger and they
were win
i have to say his decision to not
participate in world championship title
matches was so impactful and i can only
imagine how impactful it was for the
players as well we know nepomniashi we
heard from him yesterday with alejandro
and uh he seemed disappointed definitely
but also ali reza i mean
he as at 19 years of age definitely was
looking forward to the chance of
potentially taking the title away from
uh the world champion magnus carlson now
he doesn't have at least as things stand
at the moment he doesn't have that
chance anymore will that impact him in
any way what do you guys think
maybe uh something about that motivation
of playing the greatest player uh
of the generation of the time
certainly is a motivating factor is the
players are playing blitz or rapids
they they came out guns blazing and a
catalan g3 bishop g2
no
nimzos
with knight c3 um
do we play you should be seven not
bishop b4 check
yeah well
somehow they you know they have their
own fashion on the on the very high
level exactly bishop b4 used to be this
check used to be like super solid for
years right it was then standard yes and
there is no clear answer why they
stopped but for some reason they stopped
okay at least
then the open um
catalan i guess we're going for one of
the most topical lines of the catalan
yeah bishop to c6 now
bishop to f4 bishop to g5
the the most fashionable one i would
argue is the b5 move instead of a6 move
right the one that was played by i mean
was played in the world championship
match and so on i think was discovered
by grishok and then like everybody
picked it up exactly exactly but in
recent months i think it became quite uh
difficult to play at least for black
just because it gives white that extra
point you mean the pawn sacrifice yeah
yeah yes yeah the pawn secret sacrifice
and then it just it seems like white is
getting as much as they usually want to
get out of this type of positions no
risks whatsoever and uh it does seem
like that doesn't please players with
the black pieces
i noticed that uh for as far as the
world champion is concerned uh
you know it's kind of funny when you
think about these world champions how
they mature and change their styles but
at one time anatoly karpov was one e4
and you know just that was it that was
how he became world champion that was
how he kept his championship with one e4
he
he gravitated i want to say towards
being a d4 player and then you had
vladimir kramnik who was the high priest
at the catalan and yeah
it
it goes through these ups and downs yeah
with kramnik it was it was really a
strange situation because
usually you would expect that someone
you know like young high spirit plays
like sharp chess and so on and to
kramnik happened i think what happened
to kramnik was quite the opposite right
but he was very solid he
basically beat kasparov by
in a way boring him to death with you
know him
in defense and so on and recent years
before retirement kramnik was fired on
board right apparently borrowed he you
know the name of sheriff's book but
exactly
i always liked that as like you see the
scholastics players and it was very nice
in my generation probably yours as well
everybody was playing e4 joco pianos and
freight liver attacks and two knights
now you go to these world championships
they start very carefully knight f3 g3
[Laughter]
what's the current state of theory in
this very topical line uh
uh christian well a lot of games
obviously um in this position you can uh
take a couple of routes obviously knight
xd4 might actually be a threat in the
position so you have to deal with that
e3 is one of the ways knight to d to
target the bishop on e4 is another uh
one of those ways knight to d2 followed
by bishop to g6 this is the main topical
line it does seem like white is scoring
quite well so let's wait and see what al
reza has in store for us this is what
i'm seeing from ali reza i'm seeing a
player that is definitely
transitioning to a uh much more
theoretical style we
haven't known alireza is a very
theoretical player in his uprising all
the way from like 2700 to 2800 but now
that he's playing all these uh elite
level tournaments and he's no longer
playing 2650s 2700s
which he has to beat in order to achieve
that 2800 uh
rated level well
now right now he had some problems in
the candidates this is what we're seeing
from him he's becoming much more of a
theoretical player and i'm really
enjoying this phase that we're seeing
right now from him
all right thank you for that as we're as
we await uh for rouge's response i'm
just going around the
playing hall checking out our other
marquee match-up in the game between mvl
and jordan van forest funnily enough the
most classical of all the karo khans i i
relate
this line of play actually all the way
back to the 1920s in capablanca
we seem to have taken a shine to white's
setup the so-called reverse queens
gambit declined carlsbad set up with
bishop on d3 bishop on f4 bishop g5
queen b3
and in those days it was like knight a5
was the go-to
variation uh these days uh queen d7
is a very topical line and the idea is
that
people were afraid of this knight f3
bishop d6
knight e5 variation and
later it was determined that it was
rather toothless
strangely enough and so
they they stopped
being worried about it we'll see if mvl
has brought anything very special our
other player who is in this
as you said that the tie for second was
the game between ivan saric
the croatian representative and wesley
soh
these days again um i'm seeing a lot
of these very early h6g5 variations and
each one has a nuance
that if you're not careful you could end
up being just
not worse lost you're like just lost
and
or vice versa you could walk into a
variation in it and it's gone yeah oh
yeah so this h6 g5
uh well it's not literally but they say
i would be kicked from the soviet chess
school right if i would play the
combination of moves especially like
castling short and then playing h6 g5
right yeah as black as black yeah and
now every second game of joco pianos or
or this anti-burlings you are getting
this exactly and uh again if you go back
to my scholastic days uh we all
love to uh
kind of put this
sacrifice on the board this kind of a
binding pressure where we would get
queen f3 because it's sort of like
nobody knew how to defend
yeah now they know nowadays they do know
but uh no sacrifices by ivan sarge
bishop g3 knight h5 knight d2 queen b
queen f6 on the board and again
my my
my um
mind turns to mush in such positions
because i've seen so many games
uh with these with these little little
different move orders it's hard to
it's hard to keep track of every nuance
let's put it like that let's just
continue and see uh the game between
nepo
linear
this is painful this looks like
absolutely nothing nothing
thank you for stealing my thunder though
it was it has to be a pet trough and
nobody is nobody can uh yeah dent the
pet trough these days whether napoleon
yeah wait a second nepal nope
linear as well
as thabbe did also played the petrov
and
lanier actually recently had some pretty
decent results with the petrov we
remember the american cup against levon
aronian he won in a classical game and
he could have easily won in a rapid game
as well with the black pieces so he's
definitely feeling very confident in his
approach but take a look at what's
happening in the moment the arrow game
guys mamedyarov versus topalov apollo
versus montmorillon he's just a
ridiculous grunfeld that was
in the position right that's oh yes old
top
right right right yeah this was uh the
old uh stuff and i remember uh working
actually a little bit with roman gingee
harshville
um a blast from the past
on this variation i think our main move
if i recall accurately was queen hvac h4
is one of them bishop d7 is another one
of them i think queen h4 is probably the
more topical one exactly um we haven't
seen a reply from mamedyarov which is a
little bit concerning but this f3
definitely went out of fashion for
whatever reason it was in fashion five
six years ago then it completely went
out of fashion and it seems like uh
topalov is trying to revive it right now
and i recall shakri are
actually uh playing a very controversial
game in this variation
uh controversial because i if it's the
same variation that i am ascribing it to
um
he he was disenchanted with his opponent
he felt that his opponent
was not
fair
shall we say yeah
but okay well definitely we'll keep an
eye on this game i want to go
back to the game of magnus carlsen and
uh perugia we finally did get a move it
wasn't e3
it wasn't knight b2 d2 it was rook d1 by
uh
magnus yeah in fact d1 was
[Music]
relative no i mean relatively quickly by
magnus and it's fearless oh sorry who's
spending time yes okay
24 minutes yeah 24 minutes for magnus 20
left for ferruja so after rook d1 he's
on a 6 minute and 30 seconds thing
wow that's significant so he blitzed out
and now
you know what the question could be can
i actually take the horse the one on f3
not on b1 exactly
yeah so the bishop takes
the question d4 yeah okay
obviously you think to yourself the
knights in an a nice pin
and i will just capture the pawn on e on
b7 until you realize that bishop takes
b7 knight e2 is going to i did too you
hurt your feelings um the problem with
that could be king g2 move exactly so
the pin stays and yeah the knight's in
trouble as well as the b7 pawn but is it
the end of the whole story yeah because
that's uh that's the question no
absolutely not no now you have to go c5
exactly
and then e3 most likely has to be
continued otherwise you go queen to b6
and then your right is free not knight
to b3 and then we get this end game
exactly and the question is and i think
this is what he's thinking about how to
assess this and whoa
he did take out f3 after a seven minute
thing
seven minute thing maybe even longer
than that well and it's quite messy
right i can try to take on d8 i could
also
queen c3
relying upon the bishop doing yeoman's
work and uh
attacking the queen
uh the queen
yeah now you have queen b6 sorry that
was protecting the knight yeah
hold on even that even the story
continues right queen before
and
these are the end games that he's trying
to understand how to assess
i mean it's it's crazy the the line just
keeps going on and on and it's like it's
it's a never-ending story right because
again this guy is hanging this guy is
hanging yeah if we take we take it
if you play c4 rook a4
and then you have to decide
um are
are we we're not a novel territory no no
no no no this is the d1 has been played
quite a few times not as many times as
knight to d2 and e3 which were by far
the main lines but one player that
caught my eye was david howell and we
know david is working with magnus and
he's been spending a lot of time with
magnus so who knows maybe he was an
influence as well in his decision now
this feels like a rapid theoretical
preparation from magnus because in a
classical game you're probably going to
have enough time to figure things out
but in a rapid game are you going to
take the bull by the horns and take the
pawn and let yourself be pinned like
this king to g2 was played the best move
in uh the position and now he has to
follow with c5 and by the way king to g2
seems to have been the novelty in this
game that's a strange novelty i must say
mirror it's obviously the best move yeah
yeah the one that you could play like
here in a second right and here we go
c7
c7 c5 is pretty on the board as we
more or less expected now our
uh
analysis when e
three
um
because
wow i like e3 bishop takes b7 still
doesn't feel like
it's
it's a clean
um
return of the pawn e3 feels like it's
the most critical let's continue shall
we yeah knight b3
again the queen trade i think we're
going to see the queen trade
rook takes the eight
sorry uh rook yeah you oh pardon me you
think we will we will see the queen
trade takes
takes
takes
takes
knight d2 give me your knight
you know
three three give me your pawn
right and
do i play rook to a7 now because the
rook b8 my intention was to try to
embarrass
the knight with bishop takes an a pawn
feeling
like it could be very very dangerous so
you're rook a7 however okay i i don't
want to give you uh the a pawn exactly
bishop goes back right and maybe c6 if
you're yeah but f3 works yeah
three works and if you're trying to take
on b2 what happens then
b1 feels once again a little bit
threatening
rook to b1 and maybe bishop to f4 at the
end once you cover wow
um
again somebody says
somebody has been burning the late night
midnight oil i would say
uh if they were because at the moment
it's two pawns and i'm not convinced
that uh thanks to the move knight d7
that i'm not happy i'm kind of happy
being two pawns ahead maybe i've been a
little cavalier uh can we go back
actually sure so after b8
rook to b8 bishop to f8 no no no in in
in the last time
i'm sorry oh in this in this position
with the rook a7 christian right right
all right i was thinking about putting
the knight on c4 and i wanted to ask you
how you're going to get your knight out
so let's start with bishop to f4 first
okay
can i hurt your feelings with e5 you can
try it probably can
you can definitely try
i feel that might be but i liked what
you were saying there a moment ago
immediately before
um
gosh well it's kind of speculative two
pawns
but if you'd look at the knight c4
before you capture the pawn i think well
you don't have to calculate much just
just don't take on b7 you're like
and i'm claiming that white has at least
sufficient compensation for sure like d1
you know b7 is hanging i'll play a5
that feels like at least should be no
risk for white and magnus is thinking
so maybe he doesn't remember exactly
where his preparation is going
and their head-to-head matchup miro yeah
so 10 wins for magnus but three losses
as well in rapid chess and five draws
once again we can say the world
champions dominating but also being
tickled on occasions too yeah and in
case with spirulia you you don't know in
which order those things happen right
exactly the man is very young exactly
therefore like he could have lost 10
times and then beat three times in a row
right then he changes the equation
exactly where is the trend as we might
say
but these are but this is a very strange
look there i mean these two guys look
like uh
that they're working on some math
problems
who starred in that movie who was the
leading
but seriously like
obviously
you you've seen garrick as part of all
the words right i mean
he will you know just like transmit the
energy the ferocity there was some kind
of
toxic uh radiation coming from gary at
times and by the way the other point is
that even though magnus is thinking we
went for a different line completely we
went down the avenue of rook takes d8
whereas just
a moment prior
we were on queen c3 and that would be
very very interesting and also
exactly a very i think we have e3 on the
board
has to be responded in knight might be
trees
it's a
now now comes the big moment do we play
queen c3 or rook d8 once more i just
wanted to see queen c3
because it
there's something about this one that
also is attractive i don't know
queen b6 a5
queen b4 queen b5 will be met by knight
a3 and that was why i stopped but maybe
i can include that because you always
wanted to go rook to a3 maybe i can
include queen before i think then go
queen
before clever
that is uh yeah so now you're this very
strange because you've attracted you
you've helped me develop but maybe i'm
unhappy here because now the rook
is under attack right right
so maybe you have to go still rook to a3
but then i have c4 right exactly
and again the queen is going to b5 and
not to b4
and i do think we have a move no we
don't have a move yet by the world
champion
um
he might be forced to go into the end
game guys exactly that's what i'm
thinking as well maybe uh
queen c3 turns out to be a bit of a dead
end so let's try to figure that end game
out because again that's going to be
discussed um rook takes d8
ali raza is looking there like as if
he's trying to
remember all of his preparation it seems
like both of them are dying
they're doing their best in terms of uh
portraying like what how does this go
how does this go so knight d2 yeah well
that's very some very dangerous rook a3
but knight no i don't believe it the
knight d2 is the is the move right
that's
critical look for the moment but what
happens that like we have a close-up of
the board
magnus equaled in time with ferocious uh
apparently he was not expecting this
yeah yeah and he
is facing the the big decision is it
queen c3 or rook d8
now again we're looking at a line of
play where we capture on d8
and it's led us to this position where
you
know
we're very attracted to knight to c to
knight to c4
now always when i'm looking at these
kinds of things
you know i just
what happens if i put the question
uh go ahead and tell me what you'd like
to do with your bishop
yeah that's a good question
if you do go to f4 i'll take on f4 and
i'll just
uh defend
yeah you you'll be pulling up
again yeah that's that was my
living condition yeah fair enough so so
i'll have to take on f6 but then b2 is
hanging now i mean i'm probably not
worse but that's about the only
achievement i have
exactly it doesn't feel like this gets
somewhere uh christian any anything that
we're missing that uh no i don't think
so no black should be fine in this
position very close to equality and uh
it does seem like both of these players
kind of know it it was a more or less a
speculative opening choice by magnus
just allowing this bishop takes f3 and
knight d4 hoping maybe that in a rapid
chase ali reza wouldn't take the bait
but this is uh what happened take a look
at what's happening in the topolo versus
mamedyarov because that one is exploding
as well and a lot of things have changed
after uh the position we left it queen
to h4 you mentioned yasser this was the
topical line back in your days quinto h4
was played because this is more or less
an older line uh king to b1 rook feat
was played bishop to d3 and now a
mistake it seems like by mamedyaro very
easy mistake to make because bishop to
h5 seems to have been the best move in
the position it's all about control of
the f3 square if i manage to go knight
to f3 and exchange at least force the
exchange of at the knight and actually
improve my pawn structure as white
you're going to be in trouble so you
need to keep full control of this f3
square now it's easy to miss that after
bishop to f2 the only move in the
position is actually bishop to f4
putting some pressure on the queen as
well and leaving the queen on pre just
like that otherwise if you try to go
just queen to e7 after g4 you can pretty
much resign so bishop to h5 very
difficult move to make over the board
especially if you don't know it he
played bishop to d7 but right now
this is the position we're seeing and
i'm struggling to find uh the activity
for black species because i understand
the activity was very much given by the
knight the presence of the knight in the
center it was a very very strong piece
now c4 i'm just going to drop back how
are you going to improve your position
how are you going to uh continue your
attack so i can do a lot of preparatory
moves and at some point i will start
rolling my pawns down the board f4
followed by e5 i'm going to put a lot of
pressure with this pawn formation in the
center very intriguing position maybe
topalov will be scoring his first
victory in this game
thank you for that christian one thing i
have to say i'm attracted to the idea
that the queen on h4
is woeful yes and it could i start with
bishop g5 and simply try to trap you can
definitely do that yeah bishop g5 let's
go queen g3 by the way f4 on the board
f4 bishop g5
f4 is extremely tempting exactly i mean
i i don't blame uh
vessel at all bishop g5 this is really
the easiest one queen h5 and uh
bishop e2 is like this uh flashing neon
sign says uh play me
queen g3 is a strange move yeah it's a
forced move it's a force move but okay
f4 and uh i started thinking about
bishop d4 yeah i started thinking about
the move rook e3 and well at the very
least you have knight i'm hanging on by
a threat
yeah we need three something yeah he's
alive you know we're hanging on by a
threat yes
uh
but yeah but yeah okay
i mean
if you hang on you hang on uh f4 on the
board and we expect bishop to d4 i don't
think there's anything else right bishop
to d4 if you go to g7 and allow me to
lock your bishop with e5 i think you're
in big trouble i i was having so much
fun with gregory kaidan off at the
seniors closing because he had a pawn on
e5 and d5 just what we're seeing now it
was a alekhines and he had a bishop on
f1 knight on g1 rook on h1 and he played
knight e4 he didn't develop any of his
pieces now i can say to him you see
gregory how former world champions do it
you know they develop
they take the center they develop their
pieces to attractive squares effective
squares and they keep their kings safe
bishop d4
again
you know
visually it looks like white's doing
great uh this is just
it feels
not only visually and not only visual
not only visually the question is uh e5
is is maybe too aggressive miro uh would
you like
honestly perhaps i'm a greedy guy i was
thinking take kill 92 try to win ah
you're not a greedy guy you're
you're trying to join uh the pawn
grubbers club absolutely
very prestigious uh
place to enter our
hallowed halls it's a university yes
yeah but queen f2 might still be
okay and again this pawn on e3 could be
yeah well
hold on i i
i actually have
queen b4 was my original plan and i
don't know
maybe maybe there is nothing nothing
wrong with it after all no queen a queen
takes d4 when before and queen takes d4
it will be a very healthy extra pawn and
we do have bishop d4 on the board and
again uh vessel and uh
really
i think undeservedly lost his three
games yesterday he had decent positions
but he kept slipping especially his game
against magnus was
was
was
was terrible let's see here and outside
of the opening in that game against
magnus
he uh unfortunately didn't was not doing
very well but later on he picked up his
space and actually managed to equalize
uh in that game unfortunately for him
went on to lose against mvl
not so much i think he was
pretty much down not out of the opening
but in the middle game he got completely
outplayed uh now what we're seeing he's
he gets a completely winning position or
maybe a objectively winning position
overwhelming of the opening right now
bishop takes d4 knight to e2 i'm not 100
sure about that because it does give
black some chances i have the idea of f5
okay so
after knight to e2 f5 it does seem like
black is getting quite some counter play
okay
uh knight b5 was another approach though
too right
knight to b5 yes but then can i go
knight to c4 probably you're just going
to take that there is a knight d6 fork
right right okay so let's take on b5 you
may even try again f5 i'm not sure
let's take on b5 bishop takes b5 yep
take on b5 i assume the rook has to go
bishop takes d4 is on the board guys we
might actually go straight into that
line knight e2 or knight b5
you said knight e2 f5
wow
black needs to uh play uh like a
breakfast position and try to get
counter play as fast as possible
otherwise you're just busted
strategically busted break up the team
but what's the realm of knight c4
and we're going into some crazy line c
c4 sorry i was looking at knight d5 and
and was about to press my and now we're
getting some crazy lines because bishop
takes c4 i take on c4 and
uh the pawn on d4 is taboo at least for
the moment
there is a a check yeah takes one rook
takes you one rook to hd4 exactly
yeah and if i saw g6 there is a check
and there is g6 actually just simply
take back on g6 and then i have bishop
f5 coming rook to c2 there are some
complications along the way
you know it's it's funny that a move
like f5 a a move that we could easily
dismiss as some kind of uh aberration
that uh you you
your death throws a move that you don't
like to play
can actually give you a fair game maybe
an even game uh so i think right now
knight to b5 is a very important move is
is the most challenging maybe the most
critical uh can you push
er for that matter could you pers um
go in the same direction with f5 can we
go 96
well i was going to take something let's
take back with um
there's a bishop f5 sighting so if i
take back with the bishop okay take back
with us
c4
wait wait wait a minute let's go let's
let's let's take some serious material
let's take on
ea
on e8 sure okay pause pause pause
that night
we think it's coming back it's coming
back to d6 yes right
and otherwise you just take e4 and your
exchange up
uh no i i it was
kind of weird
i
i'm still not a hundred percent sure
but then i
take
yeah you still have bishop f5 which is
extremely annoying yeah precisely
there's a rook c2 sighting but
i don't know this is uh man for a rapid
chassis
anybody's game hey both players are
going to be challenged i want to just
jump back to uh the magnus carlson
foruga game because
they
followed some of our analysis
he did take on d8 he did take on a8
he did not play knight d2 uh our main
move and then
immediately bit said give me the pawn
back
rook a7 bishop f3
and this gives
ali raza this choice of maybe
going to
b3 i was a little bit isn't it drool
that's what i wrote be three i know you
go through two first and if you if
you're gonna see one then you go to a
three so that c4 can be met with rook c3
makes a little bit tricky right a little
bit but if you but having the rook on a2
does not make a very power and
also
the fact that the knight is not coming
ah you may have to
okay
but then the rook's kind of locked right
yeah no i
magnus has nothing better no absolutely
he did not play uh knight b3 he played
h6 first
he played h6 so this could allow white
to start with 92
right uh
we we're we're having trouble christian
we think knight be thrown knight b3 was
definitely a chance
in the position that probably should
have given black some advantage exactly
yeah that's slight
as
advantage
not as much as you would expect but
still another the old experienced hands
are yeah that's impressive yeah yeah
knight b3 was a
but it was begging to be played but even
now after h6 if the best move is knight
to d2 which
it might it's not such an easy move to
make right right
if that's the best move and not bishop
to f4 which allows black to get an
advantage then i have a feeling you know
ali reza is quite comfortable with his
position right now and magnus is not and
we can see that from their time spencer
as well 9 minutes and 50 seconds and
counting for magnus 14 minutes for ali
reza
and let's uh
remember how they started 25 minutes for
magnus and 20 minutes after a six and a
half minute thing for ali reza for that
bishop takes f3 and knight takes d4 that
was a critical decision exactly and for
those
uh joining us late keep in mind that
it's two points
for each rapid game for rougea won two
games yesterday that gave him four
points but he also gave up a draw for
which he got one that's why
we have this kind of a strange looking
score of four to five
after three rounds of play we get double
points for the rapid as you mentioned
coming in on our format now having said
all of that farrugia is the only player
standing at five points several players
including magnus are at four in the
chasing pact but we think
um
you know for furuja coming in with black
draws
both very good from a tournament
perspective but also from a competitive
perspective but again before the move
h7h6 just
help us out here christian had farugia
played knight b3 two questions
what is white's best line of play and
what's the evaluation
rook to a22 yes
you just look at that nero i don't know
about you but i just look at that and i
think to myself
that's the most pathetic rook
i've seen here quite some ages you know
not only that but if you think
like it doesn't matter what's your next
move if you think i can include knight
beatrice rukay too don't you go for it
of course of course every day every day
it makes a lot of sense to go for it
i'm not sure why he played uh yeah
knight d5 c4 and again could you just
give us a numerical
uh
answer like what what the computer
engine felt h6 bishop takes f6 and we
get into this line bishop takes f6
knight to c3 and it only gives black a
very slight edge nevertheless you can
look at the position and you understand
that it is only one side that is playing
for any advantage at that point and it
is black i see that dragon a2 just it
doesn't make a good impression at the
same time you do have rook to a3 coming
you have bishop to e2 to put some
pressure on the pawn the upcoming pawn
on c4 so there will be ways to get the
rook out uh with tempo i
you maybe need as black maybe a couple
more moves to cement the advantage
cement the position of the knight on b3
and then you can claim a significant
advantage if you don't get that then
probably white will be able to equalize
mirror i have bad news
i think the players have transposed into
a line that they have dismissed and said
i don't make a claim about anything i
here for magnus i think magnus just
wants to make a draw right now knight d2
by the way he did not capture on f6
right away he played knight d2 knight d3
bishop now he takes
knight takes b2
and the easy way out right now is to
just take on b2 rook to
a2 and then just go c4
but why would i have to knight to e4 is
a threat after all you know you have to
worry about knight e4
aha so knight is kind of trapped yeah
kind of c4 c4 and then we get the trade
uh
i see
yeah i think the players are just
bolting towards that position okay very
good i just wanted to go to our other
marquee matchup a game between two
players
who have scored a four points after the
first round of play first a day of play
and that is mvl versus jordan then
forest and this is the variation i was
talking about that the players in 95.95
and black said
you know what take my bishop and
you know the old guys thought these pawn
structures were
awkward for black but modern players who
plays fashionable
take your pawn structure and
no i'm doing just fine thank you very
much with black i've got
my fair share of the center
and jordan van forrest is saying
what do you
have
c4 changed completely
the complexion of the game c4 c4
knee jerk reaction
played c4
uh yeah perhaps i would because the
structure itself like white is getting
stuck right well he's solid though i'm
just saying that c4 is one of those
decisions that carry a very
good seed
of risk i mean it's not like oh i've got
the initiative yeah but he he i think he
timed it perfectly because of the c4 if
you take and bishop takes yes right so
knight d4 is not yet possible and the
rook is yeah the rook on g7 as you well
very conveniently for me highlighted
yeah does absolutely nothing in terms of
preventing d5 breaks and stuff yes
exactly off off
side
and we exp we're kind of expecting a
handshake between magnus and
it's a very solid position
i like
i like the way hold on just a second if
the bishop was on f3
it would have been and there is the
handshake
it would have been uh
weiss versus schwartz equal equal
okay magnus hasn't been getting a lot of
uh very impressive uh positions out of
the opening especially with the white
pieces
he hasn't been getting anything
so we trust him on his loss of
motivation
because that's how it looks yes
where the world championship matches
because yeah world championship matches
but as well he had two white games
against the former and
you know kind of
next match to be contender nepomishi
right and against ali reza who he wanted
to be a challenger
and he didn't show anything true uh but
on the other hand i think that just the
announcement itself
just getting this enormous pressure off
your shoulders and telling the whole
world officially you know for the last
12 months longer even i don't feel that
i have the determination the motivation
that i need
to have to win a sixth world
championship match therefore i'm
stepping down
he's still coming to grips with that as
we as are we all and uh i will
we'll see how he does by the way mira
you are making a good point but let's
not forget about his game against mvl he
forced the draw after 10 minutes of
playing that one as well absolutely in
in in that sicilian so with the white
pieces three white pieces he has gotten
nothing but we know magnus once he
starts piling up those wins he becomes a
a very different animal right an
avalanche
against c4 by the way by mvl jordan van
forest said you know what you know
that's that that's cool you got it
yeah exactly i'm going to go queen b6
you're invited in this case to trade and
rook takes and then the pawn on d4 is
quite vulnerable so mvl
shut down played c5 and said okay
now that we know the pawn went literally
from c3 where it was nicely protecting
to c5 now are you happy about it because
now the d4 pawn is a bit weaker right
yeah i tend to agree a3 bishop f6 queen
e3
rook okay that's
that's a commitment of sorts
basically saying
i am ready to invest some considerable
time and he does so rook c2 was played
in h5 here we go because suddenly
the game is flaring
uh
brightly
and christian what other games have
caught your eye
well actually i'm looking at the game of
topalov versus mamedyarov okay that's uh
the big one right and we got this
position i2b5 was indeed played best
move in the position giving white an
objectively winning position queen to e7
was played d6 and this is what we're
seeing right now d5 but how do you
respond to knight to c7 the very natural
knight to c7 just picking up the
exchange picking up the material in the
position uh i have the material and to
my eyes at least it feels like i have
the initiative as well it has white so
you can give it away and then how do you
continue how do you create your own
counter play with a pawn on c7 that you
have to tend to also with the weakness
on d4 this one is definitely going to
follow his way so let's take a look at
the cameras also from a time perspective
right now seven minutes only for
mamedyarov 8 minutes and 40 seconds for
uh vaseline but i have to say just an
easy position and i don't think that's
the one that were that was the mdl game
this is the one he should be going
knight to scandinavia that's an easy
move to make he makes it
uh by the way you you asked me what i
would be doing i'd be crying i mean i
don't like this position don't cry
i'm material ahead as you mentioned but
like you also said christian
white is the one with the uh initial
initiative
as well as the material so maybe you can
corral that pawn somehow with rupert c8
i defended rook to c1 and then you go
bishop to c6 can can i take the pawn on
c7
how do you
oh h1 yes yes yes yes you can maybe no
but that's it but after rook c8 why
don't you just play bishop e4
that's probably yeah or just then do
whatever you were planning to do but
first take the diagonal drive the queen
away and then play rugby one much better
much better
but let's jump to zagreb
thank you guys we are here with the
current leader of the tournament young
alireza fedruja you just equalized
against the world champion it seemed
like you had absolutely no problems
yes um this opening is pretty new the
knight c6 move
it came as a surprise to him so
he played very quickly rook devon which
is i think not the best move for playing
playing for advantage so
um yeah there are other better moves but
he played rook d1 very okay not very
quickly after two minutes sinking but
yeah then
i think it's all
draw so
maybe i was better a little
after
he wanted to bail out of course here
because he has no winning chances but uh
yeah maybe after bishop f3 i could play
more accurately i think the commentators
were looking at 93 or 93 in this
position instead of h6 but did you know
up to this point did you seem very
comfortable in it yes i knew that rook
devon is not accurate um but i didn't
remember but okay i calculated and it
was pretty easy
the commentators in the studio were
wondering if magnus is losing a little
bit of motivation a couple of white
games he didn't produce very much easy
draw for you here what do you think
yes it's a very tough it's very tough
these days to come up with advantage for
instance the games that i won also it's
pretty dry and my opponents went very
wrong but you had this cool idea against
sarge h3 i hadn't never seen it in the
sicilian all these years of chess but
you brought it in how do you come up
with this kind of things yes it's uh
it's a new thing um it's very
interesting
but yeah he played very good actually
and it was very dryish so
in general these days with white getting
some playable position is very difficult
alright even though it's difficult you
are the current leader what's making you
uh
get ahead of the game compared to your
rivals here so far
maybe i had better pairings for instance
than
magnus or maxim
so that could help but also i'm in
i feel like i'm playing very
fast and very good so it's good at least
oh you seem to be in great shape but
there's a very long tournament so we'll
let you arrest a little bit before the
next games guys the current leader of
the tournament alireza firuja let's go
back to the city we have four more games
left thank you very much
there i i like what he was saying like
i like the other part of the recipe so i
play fast and good moves i mean that's
my favorite part that's good uh jumping
to the vessel and topolof uh shack
uh vessel and lights your idea bishop b4
queen b5 i'm expecting just queen takes
d4 followed by rook takes c7
roxy one queen deforester and you kind
of feel like almost like a hand of
bridge you claim the win you just uh a
full exchange up and
i mean do we have any tricks in the
position knight c4 maybe after c1 is is
does that lead to anything
no
no
unfortunately no tricks uh knight to c4
maybe you can even go bishop d3 yeah
maybe bishop d3 is an issue maybe just
b3 and ask you why you're happy with
your knight on
c4 and rook to c1 is that that queen on
d4 is so powerful exactly controlling
absolutely everything bishop yeah
uh not only patrolling g7 h8 for back
rank issues but also defending b2 and
making sure that any frisky night moves
are impotent uh this looks really really
good for
for vessel in uh let's just go to annepo
for just a moment we haven't seen this
game in progress i thought like when
you've seen this
people swapping pieces on the e file i
thought yeah okay
this is gone now first of all it's still
play and this last move by black f7f6
preparation for king f7 controlling the
business squares of the e-file
i
it's
it's it's absolutely
absolutely fine who's better yeah who's
better so the thing is he brought his
knight to before young right doesn't
make a great impression yeah so unless
you have some specific i don't know
tactical idea of rookies
doesn't really make that much sense yeah
but if you start losing b2
and king g2 and i think linear will be
more than
happy to continue the game after king of
seven
we start i like the the word by the way
that uh
ali reza used here he wants to bail out
you never spoke about gary kasparov in
such a fashion as the world champion
here gary was looking to make a draw
against me he was trying to bail out i
thought that was uh that was kind of
cute uh we'll keep this one on the back
burner yvonne sarrich versus wesley so
this position blowed up wesley so again
one of our um
tied for second
um
thoughts what's going on oh well i kept
an eye
like a few moves earlier right at least
the engine okay not getting too deep in
the position the engine was claiming
that wesley was like very close to
winning a big advantage right okay so
i'm no longer sure to be honest because
this king is kind of safe yeah the
king's very safe he'll take on b6 next
move right right
so the only thing the only question i
have
is can i meet you from h1 yeah the
question is like am i getting checkmated
precisely because he [ __ ] because i
i do not enjoy it right
if you get made it that's that's too bad
because otherwise
your two connected past pawns may bring
home
a whole victory but so at least we have
to look at this end game after queen b8
queen f4 right queen b h which i
probably don't want to do
king
h7 or g7 i think queen d4 to be honest
was it was kind of cool
there's a lot of good moves
right attacking g4
uh do i though
i'm taking it back because quincy one
yeah i've seen a check i was very happy
but after quincy one i actually lose
right right right right
um
what's uh
and christian we do have uh rook takes
queen takes b six
it's a very sharp position how does the
computer
handle it
of course uh zeros
by the way also with queen to d4 even
going to d4 is zeros as well yes queen
to d8 king to h7 and i guess you just go
queen to d3 um if you do allow knight to
f5 perhaps this is actually knight to f5
which is completely losing after king to
h7 there's no way to stop the checkmate
but you still have the check on d4 this
is just a perpetual so queen to d4 is
one of the moves rook to e1 is on the
board right now right you can even go a5
if you want with the same idea once you
go to c1 i have queen to d8 queen to d8
is the square i need for a perpetual
basically after that i will have both d4
and d3 as checks depending on where
you're going to put the king so that
gives me the perpetual it does seem like
the players understand that and most
likely this is where they're going to be
storming towards but take a look at
what's happening in mvl versus van
forest maybe that one is getting
extremely exciting i have to say i'm
looking at the position opposite color
bishops but a lot of weaknesses in both
of these players positions and the
position is going to open up on the king
side with quite interesting consequences
so let's take a look at that one and
let's see how these players are going to
handle that particular situation well i
have to admit that i admire
uh mvl's
theft
did you see that theft that he created
of winning the pawn on asics
it was daylight broad daylight robbery
right here he had just played the move
knight e5 and
i think uh
jordan could have captured the knight
absolutely and with either a minor piece
he went back and look at this brazen
a6
and we have a bishops of opposite color
position
um
where
but d4
d4 falls and
i have a i have a great imagination of a
checkmate
on g1
we'll see well it doesn't magically
appear by itself so how do we feel about
the current position that we have right
now you have to find a way to well are
you going to drop the bishop back to
g4 after to g1
and then how do we assess the position
after the exchange well after i captured
the pawn on d4 well precisely so i'm
kind of reluctant to play rook g1
because if i do lose the pawn
i don't want to lose it with tempo if i
drop back right away
bishop takes
i'm kind of fearful
that the move f5
will end up
how do you put it entombing
my bishop where
rook will come back to g6 queen will
come back to g7 and i'll be in trouble
uh whether i like it or not i feel i
have to play a5
i don't know if i like it though and now
e5 exactly i don't know if i like it
because g4 is on the back he did capture
with the king
and i am expecting bishop takes d4
and
yes and before he's on the board and
isn't f5 forced by white because
i'm i'm afraid f7f5 will
will just give me a terrible f5 is an
important move yes okay so you'll have
to play it right f5 you don't have to
play it but why is it
what so you can go b4 and accept that
position but after f5 bishop h3 right
now
he does play yeah f5
it just feels like the right by the way
it seems that mbl at some point missed a
very very good chance did he yeah yeah
yeah after on move 36 yes sir okay g7
yeah he could have gone g4 yeah queen g7
and he could have gone g5 oh
yeah and then the idea is if you take a
queen f3 or something yeah you probably
go queen of three then take one f6 yeah
nice and in this case maybe my outside
pass pawn a pawn would have brought some
benefits
as what happened i think jordan is for
choice
uh by the way jordan has not yet played
e5
uh but i see also these positions can
change on time right yes because we have
the opposite color bishops whoever is on
the attack is going to have a better
position but white could easily after e5
you could imagine upon coming to f6 and
if you manage to land something on the g
file black's king might have some
difficulties well check this out
rook f6
not book f6 um
in a minute but posted dropped back with
the bishop
no he went for bb44 simply defending the
pawn descendable
and queen h6 get all the pieces on the
dark squares i like that it's kind of a
checkers right yeah
queen
rook to f6 queen
queen to h6 where the queen's going
i think he wants to play e5 and queen d2
um
i'm not sure
why didn't he prefer e5 and e4 though
as black why was was rook f6 a good move
christian it was an okay move yes but
probably uh giving the slight advantage
to white after rook to f6 the rookie is
just in a very problematic position
exactly it doesn't feel uh very good uh
e5 just felt the rock was always going
to be your worst piece
you have to find a way to involve it in
the game the way i can see that coming
after king to f8 maybe get the queen out
of the way and then go to h8 rook to g8
now from f6 that's going to add a couple
of tempe's right you have to go back to
h6 and then to h8 and then to g8 i see
b5
mvl is going for it guys wow whoa
right f6 queen h6 b5
he's trying to break things and and get
a passer no but he exactly hints on this
that your rook is not playing exactly
that's the moment for me to take
advantage of it exactly exactly
uh what do you do
do you have that expression when the
cat's away
the mice
uh the cats are all over here and maybe
the mice
will come out the board guys and huge
breaking news lately in between
and dominguez and dominion is only with
22 seconds left
huge blunder he played the move king to
f5 and allowed b3 and this just leads
tempo tempo tempo check check and i pick
up the pawn your knight is out of play
i'm picking up another pawn on b6 two
pawns down you're losing pretty much
everything at this point
jan is winning and there we go
resignation
king f5 just ended the game on the spot
king 25 was a terrible blunder
miss b3 rook rook
e5 sometimes too
when he win a tournament you need luck
let's go jump back to the uh jordan
forest game because we do have
takes
c6
on the board
how do we stop this spawning
well bishop e5
and queen d2
does have uh
it has caught my eye so let's try bishop
e5
yeah
and do we have that on the board
we don't hit the times a mirror
three three minutes 20 seconds we have a
beautiful headshot of kevin duggan there
or
cameraman
uh two minutes each three three three
minutes and ten seconds minutes
more or less each whoa again these are
those moments where yeah i do like
nerves nerves play such a crucial role
okay he's that so does yeah so does
jordan
yeah
and just stopping for the moment at
least upon from
coronation
absolutely and and these are the moments
of the game in which the game usually
gets decided exactly this time of
tension-infused moments in which
something just is in the balance right
now that pawn you just sacrifice the
pawn but you do have that incredible
thorn in black's position the pawn on c6
ready for promotion
all i need is this place the bishop from
the h2ba diagonal how do i do that is
that question queen e2 is yeah it makes
a lot of sense obvious uh answer you you
you get off the pin
uh creating a potential weakness if you
can get an f so now we go to c7 or d6
right bishop c7 feels like take
more solid but then i just take on f1
and take on e6 i don't think you can win
that uh
just
pause here just a moment because
he did play queen e2
and it almost feels like
no i
i think right now i'm just simply
getting my own play as well okay queen
four will be in a four quinty two yeah
and we do have bishop c7 on the board
maybe rook g1 is that
am i
uh
sometimes i feel i can overdo it without
even
having this feeling that i'm overdoing
it is rook g won one of those asking too
much from the position ramiro
well i don't know i would be looking at
this one or the rook g1 or bishop h3
perhaps to start with anyone is on the
board
g1 is on the board okay
king of fate seems like a response no
but then but then you might start
thinking of picking the b5 pawn some
checks and yeah
as a very experienced commentator miro
do you use that cheapo i like using that
cheapo
that when i make a suggestion for a
movie like rook g1 and they make it i go
these guys are so good
do you use that you're yourself
on occasion like
possessing black belt in modesty i'm
trying no no not not to do it okay
black belt and modesty there you've
heard it here first but seriously no i
usually uh when i start guessing too
many of those you know uh good players
moves
clearly no i clearly make the point that
it's not clear if it's
good either good for me or bad for them
right it's not necessarily a good thing
i see i see very nice uh rook g1 on the
board king f8 and again are they keeping
pace with one another no one minute and
20 seconds for mvl two minutes and 50
seconds for van forest and again nerves
time pressure
uh van forest is piling up the pressure
he's a pawn up we cover that c7 square
queen to f4 is coming hitting h2 yeah i
feel you're having you you need to be
very careful with the white pieces right
now by the way also e5 might be on tap
with an opening action of the rook on f6
and finally that rook gets to play
yeah e5 rook takes c6 would be a dream
come true i was a little bit more
worried
uh not only stopping e5 by the way but
this was the problem right here
and he has to force the end game i guess
queen before check because what else do
you do well indeed i mean there is a
mate threat
uh against h2 and now before check pick
that one up and pick on f5 and then take
on c6 as well
exactly
how do we feel about this end game i
think bishop f3 is probably just good
enough for a draw
bishop takes d5 and rook c2 we have rook
g2 right
it still feels like white is on the back
foot right now
again to quote farouja white is trying
to bail out
yes
rook g2 and you're right i mean if black
wanted to draw he could just simply have
claimed it with rook check instead the
move rook
c3 is a clear indication
oh my goodness
it seems like vessel and let his
prey escape and a draw right incredible
what incredible absolutely an exchange
you have to check
we were waiting for resignation in this
case right
uh back to
jordan vettel forest for a moment move
rook c3 by the way
it's piling up the pressure because
there is this thread of
h3 rook h3 and by the way guys
also blew it and right now he's in a
losing position against wesley
okay wesley is taking over in this one
okay rook a2 i don't want to leave this
game between mbl and
vent forest for the moment just because
we've
we've invested so much time
i mean bishop takes h2 i don't know
miura this is looking like
uh that's very good that age pawn is
is dangerous big time danger
[Music]
with shaky hands
because we do have bishop g1 shack and
follow with h2 so we maintain possession
of this very uh
yeah nice
password
right right
that's a that's a very attractive pawn
to keep in the pocket yeah and it's also
very dangerous game in terms of it can
last forever oh oh oh oh forever the
opposite colored bishop is with the
rooks that's right
you're already looking forward to the 50
move rule hurry up bishop
is on the board keep the h pawn alive so
one thing about van forest he's
definitely maintaining the pace still
two minutes and 40 seconds
i want to say that uh
jordan is a very for me at least
a practical player
i see him
having an awareness about the clock and
just
staying ahead of his opponent i want to
put it like that king g3
and yes sir you know what i've uh
recently
found out what's that that you uh were a
dutch national champion
isn't that great this happened in blitz
in blitz yeah a couple of times and in
uh
fisher 960. so have you uh gotten to
play van forest in blitz
no
no i mean we we meet each other on these
tournaments but uh more or less i'm a
commentator and he's a player
so no we haven't uh
we we haven't had a blitz
rivalry or any of those things
rook d2 oh somehow the king
found a perfect home uh
king
h1 it's actually it's time to get the
king in as well as black right king to
g7 try to get the king closer i agree i
also i always before i do anything with
a king rooks belong behind past bonds
uh it's almost
like a yeah
you two is what you want yeah
what are these bedtime bedtime
nursery rhymes
behind the best pawns and away you go
but uh you like king g7 uh change seven
king is someone let's try to get the
king in oh
jordan is reaching first yeah he wants
to put the bishop on e5 because
he won it kind of guards the pawn but it
also stops him from giving a check on
the first string but it was also
stopping the b pawn
from g1 right that's what he's getting
here now from e5 you stop bit but you
stop it all the way to b7 which might be
a bit dangerous sorry guys i mean rook
b2 yeah what was wrong with you
and then
and then when the rook finds some dark
square you get to play bishop
then you get bishop d4 and bishop yeah
okay uh bishop e5 but let's stay with
jordan's idea
clearly he wants bishop e5 and now that
he guess was the king threatening but
yeah now he goes king e7 okay now i
can't guess the moves it's time to push
right
yeah absolutely b
six bishop back to b6 on b6 okay so he
basically accepted the fact that bishop
to d4 was just a bad move yes his whole
idea
does bishop g2 kind of well not really
win the porn but
bishop jesus
yeah what does he want to do
i thought bishop g2 attacking h2 and if
you protect it then you go to b1 first
exactly not to get checkmated
he leaves the beef right now
okay this is very hard for me
immediately rugby too i mean i must say
that i would be
so fast i mean my my
my fast twitch muscle fiber would be
rook b2 uh
and he goes for it right he does it yeah
bishop g2 then yeah and we all
apparently has calculated something so
his idea was that if you start with
bishop g2 i have bishop c7 and then what
i'm threatening is checkmate with rook
to d1 and then rook
okay but well even bishop g1
right then i'm threatening the b5 pawn
so you have to play bishop c6
and then black yeah bishop d4 but he
could have improved it i'm guessing by
going bishop g1
he really wants
his bishop to defend the h2 pawn from
the g3 from the other diagonal diagonal
guys this is getting dangerous for mvl
no question about it it has been for
quite some time so we're looking at
bishop e5
rook takes f5 rook takes b5 and
well only two results are possible with
the pawn on h2 and
pawns on f6 for quite a long time
already
by the way just to remind everybody we
do have one win
already with two games remaining uh two
draws
and one win wesley also winning his game
so we're going to have at least two wins
in this one yeah so
he takes b5 if wesley wins that means he
equals in points with um
yes right and same will be
viable for well mr van forest should he
win should he win yeah following the
path uh that you yasser laid out at the
beginning of the show just make a couple
of uh quick draws at the beginning as
well
and then start picking up those
victories we have seen wesley by the way
remarkably consistent
in these rapid and blitz events
uh i remember him in paris and louvin
and
uh wherever he was playing
he was always at the top like very very
close to the to to the podium and and
should this uh let's just jump to wesley
at the moment because this one
we it's like
mbl is holding for now you're right it's
clear that
uh he will not be
you know he will not be released anytime
soon right
and now uh this is a this is a play
well
just tell me how
no this is not a game anymore it's not a
game anymore no i don't think so well
and then just
i will kick your knight away maybe rook
g1 just rook g1 force f5 go back
win the f pawn yeah
yeah yeah
i was a little
bit i was more okay he just played
knight h4 so like you said he's
defending g2
what would have happened on knight g7 h4
thank you that clears it
does that clear the cobwebs i think i
think it does yes knight h4
on the board and what did we have
g1 oh my goodness it's uh
yeah
then rook f1
okay
h1
now that we've got a nibble
yeah by the way this king on h2
that makes a pathetic impression doesn't
it absolutely
could have gone rook f1 by the way
following your advice is here sir
the problem is once uh you get the
knight anywhere else except g6 and h4 i
will play the move h4 and i win
exactly there will be a checkmating
pattern this knight goes to e7 and this
move h4 and maybe not let's check but if
i pick up the g2 pawn then the g-pawn
just promotes very quickly by the way
rook a6 and you were saying wesley on
seconds
yeah that's unusual both of them with 20
seconds on the clock
wow but here wesley just threatens rook
f6
and picking up the pawn i don't think
you can ever
let's say capture the spawn or trade the
pawn you just open up he does this but
knight h5 rook h6 is checkmate on the
very next move precisely so d3 on the
board
king to e3 but this just allows me to
pick up a little bit of jumping yeah but
then rook f5 and this is game right the
rook is off the first rank so there is
no uh
king goes
or anything of that nature king goes
back to f2 and we repeat the whole
exercise of
and let's uh jump back to the mvl
uh versus uh jordan van forsk uh jordan
nursing
two
uh extra pawns wait but
isn't this just a simple draw yeah this
does look like a fortress after king
king g4 you always go rook f3 yeah just
rook f3 and f1 you they pretty much can
pre-move it right or you give a check
and then you go back to g2 and then rook
f3 just highlights that
yeah that you have to be done here you
cannot take on f3 because that's just a
stalemate
um yeah very nice uh very nice mechanism
found by mvl to secure the draw
well i wouldn't be so uh
willing to just
say secure the draw uh on the other hand
i just don't see any way to make any
progress right
the g file then you are unable to
so
put the bishop
on g3 i'll put the pawn on f4
what will be my yeah
never happens right where you go king g4
i give you always captures oh you know
he he's waiting for f3 exactly yeah it's
probably
does it make any difference if i put no
my bishop on g1 makes no difference
and it's very difficult to get it there
also because you're losing the h2 yeah
but you know it's kind of funny maybe
thanks to the stalemates you rather let
me keep my h2
i don't know
you know
like dropping the age pawn at least i'd
be giving some checks yeah position
would change
right
okay so
yes yeah he forces this yes
rook to the second rank
yeah but but you can actually just
shuffle with the rook i believe rook
have three rooks
f1 but rook f3 bishop f2
probably don't want that
okay
everything should be a draw but at least
don't we'll just move the bishop yeah
move the bishop all the time
when f3 happens you capture f3
no matter what okay i think that's the
kind of
automated way of making it raw so bishop
to g2 i guess he wants to go bishop to
f2 exactly that was the idea that i was
thinking is trying to set up that you're
welcome to capture the h2 pawn probably
that's enough but
but even if i put my bishop on g1 i'm
not
i think mvl could just
keep his bishop on this long diagonal
and say go ahead put your bishop on g1
what do we do king g4 maybe
check king h3
then bishop f2 king g3 does that make
any difference i'm not sure
we'll do this or do this yeah like
bishop of tricking h3 at least try to
get the game to h3
so that the call is protected clock
times again
clock times yeah they've accumulated
sometime nvl is only three minutes
was it
two minutes
and 34 seconds
but it just doesn't seem like there's so
bishop f2 bishop f2 here king g3 so if
you capture
it's f3 and go figure
if it's not a lost position
right yeah rook can bishop against the
rook
this is exactly what you don't want to
do right
because
then the way this is clear
isn't he
he is
in trouble he's suffering
okay so what if i keep the bishop on the
other side of the long diagonal so
bishop d5 i let you play f3 i let you
basically get everything you want
exactly all right then you're claiming
that i still don't have any
now that the pawn is on f3 the rook is
tied to the defense of the bishop on f2
i feel
so let's go bishop d5 you go f3 i go
bishop a8 let's see
um right
wait a second it's king on g3 i'll bring
my rook to the g file right that's fine
and then i take one h3
yes the threatening mate straightening
mate on g1 that will be
that will be nice once again i mean it's
somewhat made up story i'm not sure if i
can get all the things you want but at
least yeah at least we know
where we're
where we are going where we are going
so f3 bishop f3 king of three rook f2
king takes after two it's not a
stalemate
so we do so we do get a chance to play
as you said f3
okay
so he's basically getting everything
he wants right now yeah so he gets the
rook to g5 okay and he's going to play
and king h3 he doesn't even need f3
right he can he can go king h3 if there
is no check on d7 available he can give
right like
say now after bishop
but there will be a champion yeah
there's always a
oh no now f3 bishop f3 king of three
rook f2 no but that's not the stalemate
then
h2 is not protected gotcha so he does
have f3 you can't play f3 in the but how
do you follow after that
where do you put the king is the
question
right uh
if i go to h3 you'll have bishop c8
check so the point being once you go
rook to g7 right now controlling d7
square
white has to play not bishop c6 not
bishop a8 but i think the only move
might be bishop to d wait a second so
rook g7 now yes attacking the bishop you
will have to go bishop d5 you should be
five and have that e6 square f3 and it's
almost zuk's one you might have to move
four runs into a tempo it might be a
twos one right maybe again it's getting
very close that's that's very close to a
suzwang i uh
for jordan vinforest this would be
a dream start as he said yesterday i
thought he was very
modest he said that his previous
wild cards into
rapid and blitz it had been a disaster
that he had already equaled his number
of points in the first day that he had
in nine rounds okay i have an idea so
root of the g7 bishop d5 and now you go
f3 you said right yes so i will go
bishop to c4
bishop to c4 well he's trying something
else interesting this is a different uh
because that would
your move bishop c4 would allow me to
bishop c6 now
f3
ah so
as we keep an eye on this game let's go
to zagreb
and alejandro
we're here with wesley so two in a row
wesley now with the black pieces feeling
good yeah definitely uh well first
thanks for having me here aleandra and
good to see you good to see you as well
yeah yeah i'm very happy i mean i played
like all berlin
during my black games which is a bit
boring but
it's uh what i know the best and it's
worked out well i mean ivan sark is a
very strong local player his rating is
2680
so he's very well booked up so i thought
i figured instead of going for a riskier
opening such as the sicilian i thought
just play one e45 and see what happens
and he's played this line before i did
some minor preparations beforehand but i
think i equalized relatively well and he
maybe he could have simplified to a draw
early in the opening but he made some
mistakes like we need to i thought it
was a slight mistake and gave me some
chances but uh i also made some mistakes
but the end game was crazy let's talk a
little bit
well so you said some boring opening
with the berlin you're an h6g5
this position that we have on the board
how did you assess it during the game
well i figured i have some slight
chances the main reason because this
king is stuck
and i'm just in time to stop in three
spawns but at the same time i only had
less than a minute on the clock which
was a bit worrying i mean i could have
made the draw but figured i just
yeah i think i'm just in time to stop
the pawns and why just be very accurate
to
make it apparently don't be there says
knight g8 check here forces the draw
did you feel that you had a win at some
point like when were you sure that this
was in your pocket
uh well when i grabbed these pawns
when i grabbed both queen side pawns so
when i played like uh when i played
roughly one uh i kind of controlled his
pawns and he tried making it stuck so
he's gonna run up move sooner or later
now that was a lot of zooming it's a
beautiful subzone game thank you yeah i
figured
from afar i thought this was going to be
a win so i was quite happy yeah so when
i played king b7 i thought that it's
very difficult for white to defend i
mean
i guess the main plan here is to bring
the king the black king to f2 and then
create some swan and probably also here
like i could play h4 here at some point
like i think yeah right there getting h4
but okay h4 wins alpha
but in any case i mean we made some a
few mistakes in the game which is quite
expected in the rapid game it sounds
like excellent quality from both players
especially yours let's take a look at
what's going on in the last game just so
that we don't lose our
our focus tell us about your thoughts
about this engine right now
yeah i was struggling with bethel in
before and uh a few months back we
figured there was absolutely no way for
black to make progress
but now it seems jordan is making some
progress and he just made one more pawn
move man so so you got to reset the
counter right
another 45 more moves so why didn't he
take out if he takes rook d7 what if it
takes if he takes here and then it gets
rook somewhere uh actually the
television says it's a draw in this
position after king takes h2 he could
have taken the pawn oh and then he
played bishop g there okay okay okay and
the game is over as rookie three rook
takes b3 a beautiful little stalemate
trick there at the end to finish this
one a draw between maxima shirley graph
and yordivan forest yes sorry wesley got
to ask you we had big news yesterday
what were your feelings as a player
that's participating in the candidate
cycle yeah definitely shocking i mean i
thought the
magnus was still a big favorite like
what he told me that maybe
you know magnus just wants to go out and
win but he's clearly by far my opinion
the strongest player so it's very
shocking i mean i can understand that
he's played a lot of world championship
matches already
and he doesn't want to play i guess 14
classical games and there's a lot of
training involved and
maybe he wants to do other things
but
yeah definitely shocking at the same
time i
feel this will give other players more
chances and more initiatives so a player
like you
yeah yeah i mean
i think uh mike has been number one for
11 years so it's
quite depressing
for other players so now that he won't
be part of the world championship cycle
then it's a big five relief but uh it's
definitely interesting because he's very
young and um he's
got a lot of gas left on his tank but
um
we'll we'll see what happens uh he's
here
absolutely well wesley will let you go
because we're a few minutes away from
the round thank you for being with us
let's go back to the studio and get
ready for round number two of the day
thank you alejandro thank you wesley
we'll go to our standings uh miro after
uh round four is completed
and here they are
oops
no we don't have any problem yeah we
have a tie for the first that much i can
tell you so wesley after this win
catches up with ali reza right and
what's more important than the standing
season because it will it's a subject to
change but what's not changing is the
fact that q boutique has an offer today
let's do it let's do it tell us what's
the special um
this time it's a lightweight cotton
zip-up gray jacket with pockets and the
grandchester logo on the front left as
you can figure out well sometimes it's
mirrored
well but i made sure this one is on the
left well done if it's yeah if it's
possible
but that's today's offer i like those so
i might be getting one myself exactly
go to q boutique st louis dot com and
that will be our feature and uh
as we go to blake we asked our players
what is what their feelings are like
playing in zagreb and these are their
answers
welcome back to the grand chester and
zagreb how does it feel to be playing in
the city
it feels great i mean uh
it's uh the continuation of the granches
tour
for me in a way it feels like the
beginning of a new season because i took
a long break after uh
bucharest in that sense it feels like
i'm
ready to to start a new season and of
course at the beginning there's always
some uh
uncertainty because you you never know
how it will go but then after a couple
of rounds you realize that it's uh
all the same it's uh as usual so
yeah very much looking forward to this
one uh it feels great especially after
last year where i played quite a good
chess and this year
i'll be able to play in both events
rapid and blitz and
i'm really looking forward to
it and for me
for me personally this is one of the
most important tournaments in a year
oh it's really great i mean i'm in a
very
vocational mood because also it's first
time for me to visit croatia i really
like it it has this uh
kind of volcanic
uh i feel the atmosphere of
ex-yugoslavian countries i played here
every time
little bit
strange tournaments but i hope this year
i can play good tournament
i like zagreb and this year i come with
my friends the
injury from zagreb
walk
and also i hope with my friends i will
play much better i would say it's one of
my favorite countries
probably
[Music]
you know mostly because of you know the
southern part like split
it's just it's just very nice i mean i
really enjoy spending time there but
here in zagreb is also like
very very nice city center and we uh we
like to stay here and i'm
really looking forward to spend some
time walking around the city oh yeah
it's great to be here actually again
since i was here last year as well
so yeah it's just
for me it's a big honor to be part of
the grand chester it's all the biggest
gesture in the world and all the best
players are playing here so for me it's
a big you know opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
and to try and
do my best here let's say and get some
points with them yeah i like it here in
croatia so i've been happy to
to go outside to
you know recognize a few sports i know
here and
yeah i hope to
to be able to
not only play chess play good chess but
also visit against this way town of
zagreb
i'm very happy and pleased
and i'd like to thank granchester
the sponsors and organizers for hosting
another event i had a pretty lackluster
result in poland
the same format so i'm hoping to be able
to bounce back but i'm very excited this
tournament is going to be stronger than
ever and
very pleased to be here hopefully i put
enough preparation to play well yes it
feels great i've been here once during
european team championship
it was not organized here but we took a
car and came it's a very good city
especially in summer it feels very good
and the tournament is there
is a very good quality tournament so i'm
happy to be here feels very good to be
here back in in zagreb
it's really one of
my my favorite cities i had a great time
here
last time i was here
now i arrived just yesterday but i've
had some time
today to have a have a long walk
and see the city again and it's it's
nice to be here
very comfortable in terms of
temperature as well so
it's good
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2020 grand chester
zagreb beer are our standings after four
rounds of play mural yeah so as we said
ali reza perusia is joined by wesley saw
who has won his game in fourth round and
then we have a three-way tie for the
third between magnus thousand
maximushiela graf and jordan one forest
and our parents for this round five uh
feature the farouza mvl i like that
yeah that's uh that's an interesting
derby and then mommy giaro faces
allison dominguez the paul of wesley saw
against nepal mishi and young
jordan environment forest is against
surrey and i do assure you lanier has
more points than that
and we have the game between farouzia
and mvl which i think is hilarious
and i we we're talking about trying to
get an advantage in the opening and i
just gonna have to ask
uh christian
uh whether anybody in the history of
chess has ever played this line that
ferocious essayed with h3 and g4 oh
absolutely no
great players come on
great players have played it in fact
uh after h3 has been played let's see
how many times 33 times and after g4 it
was actually played only three times but
really good games karjakin versus
grishoug gledura versus jeffrey chong
and goncharenko versus perez lopez which
i do believe it's a correspondence game
so
this has definitely been played what
surprised me
more is that mvl came with this
novelty d5
in this obscure line of the sicilian hd
g4 and that actually made alireza start
thinking this is what we have right now
queen to e2 and knight to c6
mvl keeps blitzing out his moves this is
the most impressive facet of this game
right now that i'm seeing it's just his
preparations quick
yes
observation so yesterday we were talking
about brilliant novelty by mvl in the
sicilian on move six right guess what he
just beat it by playing default same
move d5 but one move earlier in a
different position
incredible impressive impressive uh the
the preparation even for something
that's obscure 33 games out of i don't
know 6 million in our database uh h3g i
haven't seen it in d5 or and
well the the wonderful thing is that
after queenie sex check queen e2 knight
c6 d3 we actually have a full-fledged
game uh yeah
the pieces are all on the board they're
flying queens can be traded of course
but if you uh allow white the
opportunity of playing bishop e3 you
might end up with an embarrassed queen
on e6 so if we do take
take
um
first impressions are that i kind of
like whites i like my king in the center
with the queen's off the board what's
your take yeah well did white get
something honestly i wanted to compare
with the line with second move g3 you
know
you get the queen e6 check and so on and
in comparison yeah maybe if it could
just you know show it
yeah i think g3 is the move
knight f3 i'm not sure what you should
move is yeah bishop g4 yeah bishop gt2
and then you have this check queen e6
check it out
f1 yeah
i played this as white on a number of
occasions in
blitz uh online blitz not and you go
h3g4 so we do get some parallels with
with what we have on the board so how do
we feel about what mvo decided to do and
that is h5 now where do you put the king
as white in this type of uh situations
i'm not going to take on e2 i'm going to
allow you to take on e6 and exchange the
queens by on my own terms so i want to
wait for you to do that h5 probably g5
has to follow you cannot take on h5 well
this is the key moment right uh
uh
if i'm doing options yeah if i'm going
to play the but what's the follow up
with the question what's the follow up
with with the queens on the board takes
takes takes h1 you can take on g4 i'll
take on c5 but i'm not even sure i want
to take on g4 fair that's okay
what if i go g6
g6 i may
ask you the question
what you
okay now i take now that you're forcing
my hand i will take
okay so then trade and take on c5 m
something like this then bishop h6 maybe
bishop h6 maybe
even though maybe i actually no bishop
g7
let's just play bishop g7 normal movies
yeah normal moose would you can still
not castle right so i might as well
now castle myself can i do that
you take that i take on d3
okay castles
we perhaps have to stop there because
it's right you're far far away from the
uh well okay so h5 uh kind of throwing
down the challenge to white
do you allow me to take on g4 or do you
want to play g4 g5
looks like
on the board is that clear
apparently yes all right i think we have
some transmission errors but g5
on the board on the board okay
yeah and
and we all
and we do have that ah he's not he's not
seated because he's not at the board
from the camera it looked like yeah
so he must be he must be singing
but he doesn't play g5 so what do we
expect now g6 and bishop g7 g6 looks
very attractive since you stabilized the
queen the king side maybe you're not
afraid anymore of white
kind of avoiding the queen trade you're
right you play g6 bishop g7 castle short
well one of the nice things about
provoking the pawn to g5 is that
i'm never really threatening to take on
on e6 and jump with my knight to g5
anymore
okay so
g6 um
i want to embarrass this queen because
i'm just thinking
that the queen is sitting
on the diagonal that the bishop wants to
occupy so say bishop e3
bishop g7 c2 c3
gift the pond
yeah but huh
can i
i'm really hoping that i provoke this
move i'm not saying it's a good or bad
move but at least i have ideas
yeah i do too i do like white's position
a little bit and and guys just while mvl
is uh out uh maybe doing his uh thing
magnus might be in some trouble magnus
versus shaq against mama dyarov he's
taking some very enterprising risks by
playing the grunfeld seems to be maybe
not in his preparation but quite
comfortable with the position
nevertheless that pawn on d6 makes a
great impression for white
yes
what if i just simply go bishop to g5
now
e6 d6 and while bishop d7 yeah bishop to
g5 now why not i mean this is a typical
way to try to create some weaknesses in
your position
okay
let's uh you don't so you don't play f6
yeah i kind of like to keep this bishop
diagonal open for a moment yeah but how
do we how do we reply to bishop e7 then
rookie yeah okay yeah and i was hoping
for some night jumps like knight e4
probably you jump by jump right right
right five knight g5 maybe and try to
get the other knight to e4
knight e4
let's say bishop looks somewhat
dangerous
knight f6 check or this knight yeah
yes something of that sort yeah perhaps
started with knight g5 i think that was
a
smart way uh i i don't know about
putting the bishop on e7 this always
feels a bit dangerous double-edged for
me
bishop d7 on the board bishop g5
bishop iv was played
before was played maybe he was
obliged to play f6 because that
variation that we just played through
where you put a knight on f6 that
definitely felt uncomfortable to me so
maybe bishop g5 i would have met with
hindsight with the move f6 bishop f4
right away
ideas of knight e5
uh tell me what you want to do bishop c6
i want to put my knight on default this
knight on b6
i'm not happy it needs to
it needs to work yeah yeah yeah maybe it
does yeah even after 95 maybe you don't
not care that much about the bishop on
c6 you just get an id5 you you can help
yourself right help yourself to the
bishop
uh for example 95 knight d5
if you'd like to take
takes
the question is what kind of position is
that yeah i should be okay bishop c6 on
the board by the way
now the other thing
after 85 could it be that we take with
the bishop and then go f6 because
sometimes it is
a very valid thing to do right i see
these benoni players playing bishop
takes c3 so they can take a pawn on e an
e4 or something and it's like wow
bishop takes e5 bishop takes e5 f6 yeah
f6 and there's also g5 which i'm not
gonna have mixed feelings about it like
queen g5
yeah would be nice to say it wins it
doesn't yeah bishop g3 yeah
unfortunately i don't have to read three
but maybe and now i don't know i put one
rook on d8 and then try to try to claim
that i'm not that
not that scared of you yeah
yeah just uh there is still this
half open a file
weird things may still be a foot uh but
definitely an intriguing position what
else is going on uh a lot of very
aggressive sicilians are going on
actually in the game
uh van forest and sarish check this out
like some sort of a dragon but this is a
super weird dragon and check how we got
this position so we see this bishop to
b5 bishop d7 bishop to e2 now we go d4
and open up uh the sicilian and we have
this position bishop comes to c6
impending the action of the rook on the
c file i don't necessarily like this
move bishop to c6
because also i feel like f3 actually
helps white to improve uh his position
and this is what we have right now it
does like we're most likely going to see
a melee you're going to attack me on the
queen side you're getting ready to go b5
b4 and try to open up the position there
i'm going to try to open up the position
on the king side h4 h5 or with g5 first
that's the first sicilian that i'm
having my eyes on
another one is this dominguez versus
topalov to follow bringing out the guns
early on and uh this is currently uh the
position that we have a najdorf in this
one as well bishop to e3 e6
g4
we have the uh i think it's called the
keras attack with an early g4 this is
the position we have right now only one
game was played between harshid raja and
antova in 2018 so quite unexplored line
that is and uh nepo just doing nepo
things getting better position
with the black pieces out of the opening
against wesley so and wesley is down to
his 17 minutes while nepo has 25 minutes
so definitely a big preparation for nepo
seems to have given him the advantage in
this one with the black pieces
thank you for that christian one of the
things that gary kasparov pointed out
and
an interview that we had with him about
the candidates as he said i forgot
that in your preparation for a world
championship match
you're creating libraries and you can
kind of carry
all of those novelties and ideas that
you made for the match into your next
tournaments
and we're seeing that with nepo whether
it be in his petrov or even in his game
today
with wesley he's got a very comfortable
position
he's he's got the muscles from the world
championship match pair preparation
mural
by the way as we were coming on the air
is talking with miro about
well everybody's talking about the
abdication of the world championship
match throne and you had a brilliant
witty comment that you had caught from
michael todd yeah that's the one yes
so well
uh
well just stumbled on this on some
social media but yes so that magnus in
fact he's went for another title
that the most pleasant title in chess
the title of xwell champion and the
point is that that's the title you hold
for life you don't really have to defend
it you cannot lose it yeah so that that
that that was it very nice title yeah i
mean so i mean an accumulation of titles
by magnus carlson he's been the world
blitz champion he's been in the world
rapid jazz champion but now he's also
the world ex-champion and he can't lose
it he's still he's still is and he can't
lose all the matches played right and uh
i love this uh
these really really ultra sharp
sicilians that we have between lanier
and vesselin
where i think that with lanier
especially too we're talking about a
very very well prepared theoretician and
i always liked to see these theoretical
battles uh what's your first take when
you see a
very sharp
keras attack position like this
yeah i mean do you start thinking about
95 ideas oh yes because well it was the
power of debating these positions with
both colors i believe like yeah there
was this toppal of kasparov
silly gromnick beat the polygraph
it was all those like very sharp
sicilians right not exactly that so it
was with f2f3 right but also pushing the
kingside pawns and so on
and back then
it looked like they've established like
a very narrow path of very good moves
and later on as with the computers it
turns out well on every single move you
have an alternative that's the problem
so now i look at this position i like
white i think white is like like getting
something developed and just run a
computer engine and they would say no
black is okay we saw you know five
different moves
which might not be true remarkable uh
christian in the game between lanier
and vesselin
are we still in theoretical waters well
there's been one game played uh one day
early i was born the great 1991 so the
great nineteenth
it's been a while since this position
has been played for good reasons
probably because after f4 it just
doesn't seem like black is getting their
attack going right you have this nice
pawn on a3 stopping any sort of
initiative on the queen side and i'm
just pushing my pawns f4 defending pawn
on g5 i'm going to follow it up with h5
g6 open you up on the king's side and
unfortunately once again i don't see
your initiative on the queen side this
is what concerns me about the position
and you are mentioning mirror that the
computers might be saying that black is
fine black is not fine
right now
in uh dire straits after move f4 queen
e2 castle i have time as white so
definitely liking what dominguez is
doing in this one and maybe we can jump
back to uh magnus's game because uh some
things have changed in the
identification as well
uh
magnus followed your advice uh
poor magnus uh will he recover uh join
us
premier subscribers
knight e5 bishop takes if i hear i was
kind of making i was about to make or
attempting to make an argument for the
move knight d5 inviting a very different
type of pawn structure if you will allow
me for a moment
it's it's not a white pawn on d6 or a
black but
maybe you know what maybe he's not
capturing so he takes on c6 in this
position he goes bishop g3 you're
welcome to take c3 but i see at least d6
is like
exists for sure and also you you're
getting some weak pawns yourself rook c1
rook c6 this i
don't like for white exactly
and
also in terms of novelties i think
bishop g5 had actually been played
before bishop f4
seems at least
from the lee chess database that i have
in front of me uh a novelty bishop c6
bishop takes this is where you had kind
of like
made
this idea
he didn't go for queen g5 yeah
he just said yeah queen d7 make it that
the d pawn is showing slowly slowly yeah
e5
i'll play knight d5 bishops of opposite
color but
here's the point uh asset or liability
the pawn on d6
for the moment at least looks great he's
just played queen d
did he hang on three queen d3 or d8 yeah
you did hang his pawn on yeah
yeah he's what he wants to do
rook takes a seven night siatus
uh
apologies just finish it off i think you
can take yeah
and no there is no pin
the seven is protected exactly one
rookie one there's no pen
right now yeah i just wanted to make
sure that uh there was nothing there
uh
rook d8 on the board but knight to c8 is
still a threat so how do you defend
against that is the question
right so if i start with rook d1 and you
go knight c8 eventually you will be
threatening e5
can i disturb you with b4 and b yeah
maybe b we can try
a6 right
that looks like a kind of a
universal answer
and once again
i think black is the one that got helped
by this sequence exactly exactly so
well actually it's not that easy to play
with white all of a sudden yeah you do
have this beautiful tone on d6 but
what's the follow up right maybe time to
pull the brakes
bail out bailout
knight wait a sec some knight e4 thing
i'm probably blundering bishop b5 even
though i'm not sure
bishop should be five some queen move
i'm not sure which one in knight c5 yeah
and
who knows
uh uh unlike the six yeah i was thinking
about that
right well it would be very nice if i
got a chance to do that yeah
well um
so it looks at least like shaq has to
answer questions d1 was played he played
rook
to d1 so he keeps the rook on f1
i think he wants to put the rooks on uh
the central files and then basically
once you play the move e5
in all the scenarios i'm going to meet
that with the move f4 that's why so
knight to c8 i go rook to u1 i wait for
you to go the e5 and then i go f4
and try to bail out like this
even that's not clear to me uh because
your
bishop is going to be
kind of hanging right e5
f4 let's say
queen takes just and now i have queen c4
queen c4 yeah that's right
very important little check that is a
very important little chat yeah takes
takes
five same choices available and then e6
yeah now it's starting to get a little
bit tricky for have you ever
seen that the d6 pawn yeah yeah like
d6 and we are calling it the very strong
pawn and so on and then like finally
wins it but now it's an e6 which is a
very strong force
black has to care about yeah black
finally wins it you know
uh no that's a very that's a very
unusual sequence that is not
anything i'm very familiar with and
probably after rookie one i rushed
the move
e5 and oops excuse me i did that wrong
let me just refresh my board i've got
the wrong situation on my board
uh excuse me for
this
uh
after rook d one knight c eight that's
what we saw rook to e1 i probably rushed
with e5 and things like that maybe i
should just maybe move the queen and
then the default and then play e5 in
this much more slow
fashion so that i don't fall victim to a
and that is the key word right now black
has to just be patient in reposition
corral the pawn on d6 and then go on and
try to put pressure on it now let's take
a look at what alireza is doing because
i have a feeling he's taking over right
now against mvl and that's a huge match
for the standings it truly is
same we all ended up trading the queens
the moment we were discussing g6 how do
we feel about this endgame because i'm
seeing white opening things up with a4
creating a lot of weaknesses in black's
position and i don't see a very good
response
for a black alternatively so
it's not looking good to my eyes see not
at all
and then yeah a4s if i can blow up the
queen side and especially with the rook
on a1
um
white will be for choice he'll have to
reply with b4 i'm guessing exactly
you're forced to go before once i go a4
some live like bishop i don't know okay
six perhaps yeah bishop e7 maybe knight
d5 yes it's a little awkward okay so
bishop d6 d6 a4 right i like it i like
it very much for uh
before i go rook h
c one right it's a h to c one now i have
a big threat uh i think i'm threatening
to take on b4 right yeah perhaps
nothing wrong with that move but i'm
also not averse to stopping knight a5
forever
and uh
really i've played these
positions as white uh colors reversed
like my whole career and i've done very
very well with them uh very successful
uh the these uh setups it doesn't seem
like you have a good follow-up as black
anything you move weakens the position
yeah in one way if you move the knight
they can take on b4 and then
this is c file this is the current
position we think that a4
alireza as you said uh could be taking
over and
he would be flying oh yeah
i mean
forget the candidates i mean this is a
new event happening yeah midnight never
even i mean
and with wesley so with wesley under a
little pressure in his game with nepo
uh
that would be uh well received and how
is jordan van pores doing yeah jordan
forest against
saurage right yeah
that one is
wild right now
there's a rook on c3 hanging
obviously you cannot take it but still
there's rook on c3
there are some checkmates coming your
way as well as black for example what if
i go f5
f4 f5 right here right now let's open
things up f5 followed by f6 or g6
you know there's a wonderful story of
miguel nightoff where he explains that
he defeated alexander alekhine in a
blindfold symbol
h5 what and uh
he defeated alekhine by sacrificing a
rook on c3 that was not taken and then
he sacrificed his rook on a3 so
it's the first time i ever get to show
the idea
that rook c3 could not be captured rook
a3 could not be captured but in this
case maybe it can
uh you know
yes it's a beautiful beautiful idea okay
maybe it can yeah king a1 and i don't uh
it's a check on b1 what is what is a
nice myth but you take with the rook
yes rook p1 rook takes queen d2 and you
have a check right and who who
checkmates whom
i mean it
it goes on by the way
take it with right
check right g7 and there's still a lot
of threads right
that's crazy uh
f6
yeah but the rooks are not very
kind of not very threatening right and
you're just hoping for a thing so anyway
at this point
it's a funny
line but it was a wonderful story
rook c3 rook a3 but he took on h5 he did
not play
yeah f5 but she was like a3 right yes
and now rook a3 is actually a valid move
right for the very same reason that if
you take your king a1 this rook b1 still
works
bravo
are you
are you familiar with the story who's
telling the story here you're you're
doing very well um
with the story uh
king
b
one yeah rook b1 i think it does work
here okay so let's i i think that line
is forced rook to b1 what an
extraordinary a line
if you don't go rook b8 it feels like
actually queen takes queens
check on b8 take the knight yeah
but uh do you get to cover c3 here
because the oh you go rook c8
i have nothing
not rook b8 but rook c
rook c8 and then i give you a check
and here
you it's almost like you need to play
here so that you get to attack the
bishop somehow
and then general pb1 is a problem
uh a remarkable sequence
and after bishop takes h5 i think yvonne
did something h5
knight takes h5 h5 hang on what's like
h5 well maybe we get the sequence with
rook a3 and then the way to start
okay it doesn't make any sense but i
mean any other myth doesn't make sense
right we have here you have to take and
then what does he do
rook a3 again okay
but isn't white
faster somehow
well
that is made into day two
you mean rook rook takes
rook h7 doesn't rook a2 yeah queen wait
a sec queen d4 you take a go b3 can this
be right
okay because it does stop you for quite
some time right a little bit pause
because i have b three
don't make me calculate this stuff
please yeah it's like please no this is
not the lazy man's uh
you know it's funny i i i
he inspired so many people michael tall
but it would that was the type of move
that he would play
and everybody was just frozen after this
so you wanted to say that rook a2b i was
hoping this is a kind of a showstopper
yeah but is that true uh really mature
rook takes age seven and you get there
first i'm not sure again i mean you
can't change yeah sure because there is
a check here trade everything takes h7
yeah so that's a crazy position we're
having too much fun with it with what's
going on over here christian uh uh clear
our cobwebs uh what's happening in this
crazy game between jordan and uh even it
seems like knight takes h5 was in fact a
big blunder now the engine is saying
that white has a decisive advantage plus
seven wow now forget about the plus
seven and what yeah this is a position
between two humans and there's a lot of
checkmates hanging in the urine but what
i was looking at was the variation that
we were looking at which was proposed by
the engine as well saying that this is
in fact quite okay for a black this
position take take sorry not with the
rook on h5 with the knights this
position
crazy with the knight still on g7 and we
were looking at rook to c8 and there's a
hidden motif right now so first
you go queen to g2
what attack the rook on each one and
then take advantage of the fact that the
rook on ceo
and queen to h3
bishop and the rook
very difficult uh motif to see and spot
from afar and this actually would have
given black the advantage if you go rook
to c8 you have to go rook to b8 and uh
force black to give some sort of a
perpetual in that position rook to h5
this is what we have right now in the
position and if you are starting you're
seeing a checkmating attack coming in
the next couple of moves because queen
to d4 as you guys were pointing out
followed by rook takes h7 that's going
to lead to a checkmate you have to do
something fast rook to a3 makes the most
sense to my eyes in the position you can
try to go b3 first but then i can just
simply take right and that's not
that might be problematic also i can
just simply take and then run with the
king so rook to a3 is in fact on the
board
let's see how white uh van forest is
going to react to this one
well we think the queen d4
rookie 24 is is is a draw
queen d4 is a draw right right right
actually that was our
my best move in the position is in fact
keen to see one king to see one is the
winner
stop it king the c1 of course
that's the last thing i'm thinking
what's that king c1 rook a2 yeah that's
exactly what i'm wondering so it's
basically a mutual zeus one almost
stay with me for a second stay with me
for a second if you take on a2 i go
queen to d3 threatening and now you're
getting checkmated on h7 i'm waiting for
you to react if you start with rook to
d4 oh with queen to d4 sorry the move
that you guys wanted to make right
now it's black's time to wait so after
queen to d4
i will take on a2 you go b3 right
and now i'm waiting for you to take on
h7 so i'm going to go rook to uh b5
let's see okay some sort of a threat
queen brook takes d5 i think is a threat
if you do take on h7 i have rook to a1
first
right and then we go into this end game
exactly
so i'm waiting for you to put your root
camp pre so that i can give this track
group to a1 and force uh the exchange of
the pieces major pieces and the move
king c1 it's a ridiculous move
it requires you to play rook a2 is the
only move that wins in the position
now you have queen d3 that's that's
that's one guy you're waiting for the
rook to leave the third rank and then
you
then you play well
i mean that's too sophisticated
it's really good i don't see it pixie
one is just such a move that you know
you if he finds it check his pockets
exactly uh
arbiter orbiter uh but mutual zukesvar
explain to our viewers how you would
this he's reaching he's going
and he's looking for a1 like thomas
our viewers understand and he's done it
oh my god what is zug's wong but what's
mutual zug's won what zooms this is a
crazy concept from zuk's one we
understand yeah it comes from those
studies yeah made up positions yeah
where each side doesn't want to move
basically right exactly each move well
the tuk swang is like you are to move
and each move kind of worsens your
position leads to some unpleasant
consequences but there are exceptional
positions in theory of end games
especially right when neither side wants
to move like we get well the simplest
would be the opposition king and paul
versus king endgame right
i'm to move please i'm not winning right
right you're the move you're losing yeah
well these things yes so one of the ways
i thought of uh zugswong when i was
growing up is this idea that i've put my
pieces all on their best squares
they're they're they're ideal
but now it's my move and i have to
lessen one of them i have to move one of
my pieces off of its ideal square so i
don't want to do that i'm in zuk's wong
i have to worsen my position but mutual
zook's one yeah man that's rough uh but
neither side
wants to move
because they worsen your position king
c1 and this marches finishes the game
right what a move because i have a big
threat i'm threatening to take your rook
now now you're finally threatening to
take the rook because it's no longer a
discovery if you stay on the third rank
i'm going to double up on the h file and
you're going to get checkmated
so if i s well actually let's
see if that's true because
queen takes a2 is a big threat as well
so if you're not playing rook takes a2
and queen d3 wait you can go quinny to
attack the rook and if he's captured you
go queen d3 anyway right look at four
queen d3 same thing right so let's stay
on g3 in that case well that then i was
really afraid it goes back back to c3
back to seeking something similar i was
afraid that rook g3 would only encourage
queen h too yes and then i i land
on
h7
i'd be tempted to say i had enough and
go king b1
with understanding you know like
a forced repetition
rook c3 well does that move
possess a perfectly honest everything
wins for one queen d4 d4 yeah
that's the move you just you just kind
of get out of dodge you you're kind of
opening up
ideas of rook h7 and to take the rook
frame all right so queen takes a2 um
you just no no no you take the rook
really well why not i'm rook up i'm
enjoying being broke up you know
[Laughter]
obviously yeah but
the game's over you have queen b65
windows d3
v3 coder i don't think you have any
checkmates no no unfortunately that's
why
right
check on g2
how do you escape the tracks
that would be uh do i escape the checks
yeah that's uh
yes you do queen to e2 queen d5 and our
king e1
there is no more queen to h4
that's a that's a good that's a goodie
your h1 is it's covered so somehow you
escape wow what a
what
you know yeah
that's a fancy footwork you know that's
like a little uh little dance
around the board by the white king rook
c3 you've got to give ivan sarich credit
that is quite a sharp move but also
taking the rook i understand a rook
ahead
but
can i do
what with 4.82 what is your big threat
there right
can i do well
can i go for the checkmate no but queen
takes a2 is a big threat yeah d4 queen
takes a 2 and great takes two right are
you you want to take on h7 anyway or
queen e4 yeah but e4 is kind of safer
way of achieving more or less the same
right i want to get my queen
on this diagonal so that i land
with the queen on h8
so queen d4 queen a2 queen e4 no but
then no it's just resigns yeah so well
that's now i run the propeller
you know what uh
what uh
joe lewis said hey let me run
you can run but you can't hide
he can run but he got a
rookie one this is not looking great not
looking great
by the way
jordan van forest
would be on a tier
because
against mdl he was enjoying
a two-pawn advantage and it was a a very
about will he find queen to d4
and look if you find king c1 yeah
i mean hats off queen d4 is a easier
find
than king c1
wow king c1
and by the way we
like to announce that
ding laren will join us in about 20
minutes uh skyping in and
giving us his reactions to the wonderful
news he may be involved in a two million
euro uh world championship match uh how
important was that last round victory
over there was a lot of things happening
for ding liran like entering the
candidates he had to play like he was
qualified by rating but he played a
bunch of different games at the very
last minute all arranged in china
raised a lot of suspicions but hey
uh that qualified him
then he was in the seller the first half
went completely wrong including his
opening round loss
against nepo with white but he
fought and fought and fought his way
back and a very deserved second place
finish
this he will be joining us in 20 minutes
and his reactions to uh the news that
magnus
is abdicating is uh going to be very
interesting
speaking of yes
yeah this one
this is wonderful but yes all five games
are in progress i wanted to go to the
mvl game for ruja
well actually speaking of bailing out
yeah somehow uh mvl is in there with a
shout magnus against shakriar
uh the pawn on d6 is still on the board
by the way but yeah but the magnus is in
exchange up right so the the question
remains if he is able to surround the d6
pawn
sharp
[Laughter]
yeah true true that but the what you
said it's not so easy to round up the
spawn i do
see five comes yeah that bishop will be
anchored for life c8 or rook to b8 is on
the board rook two e8
b8 b8
magnus yeah i have to say he's capable
of finding moves yes yes
that
yeah because i was about to warm up to
shakriar's position shaq puts the bishop
on c5 and it's
yeah it's very good it's very nice
so that rook c8 is possible in some
cases but also have to stay still he was
played now
bishop f2 plan on meeting rook takes b4
does he just want to give up yeah like
pawn and go bishop c5 and follow it up
with the other pawn coming to b4 yeah
maybe that's the recipe yeah bishop we
do have bishop f2 on the board
but bishop c5 rook to c4 it worries me a
little bit but
really i mean i'm kind of stunned that i
can't just play queen c7 and
d7 like guys always good
c4 you know all those dynamics [ __ ] c4
okay because here i had this beautiful
idea of d7
and to try to make you cry
but bishop ripped the c for bishop
something else makes me cry guys what
happened uh one forest and sorry they're
repeating
that would be that would be very sad
yeah i i cannot believe they're going
for that
sorry you were going to say rook c4 so
once again if i was
no yeah quincy
to c4 bishop to c5
and then my dream of course is the dream
comes true but if you go back then i
could do you wait for me to give a check
and go forward in fact oh i beg your
pardon like rook c1 if king h2 maybe
some queen f5 happens i agree
they did
no
look at those big smiles as both players
are kind of disbelieving
of
what just took place one of the most
unusual disbelief repetitions i've ever
seen i gotta tell you rook a3 rook c3
uh jump in christian if you if you've
seen something as remarkable as that no
no no no
it's ridiculous and it goes uh to show
how exciting rapid chess is right
because in a classical game i have to
say he would have found queen to d4 i
think by the way the clock ticking down
and you having to make sure you're not
giving away any checks that the king run
king to d2 king to e1 it wasn't easy to
find right allowing queen to a2 on the
board comes with its own risks and
consequences and they're not easy to
take with only five minutes on the clock
we've seen king to be one king to c1
what can we do wonderful by the way i
want to say wesley
we thought that things had gone against
him and they have he is upon down in a
rook ending but in a rook ending i would
say that's very likely to be drawn
and so wesley keeps chugging along you
know
mixing a few wins uh some drugs and
finds himself in the thick of the
leadership but that's that's i think
right now it's it's it's just about this
game this game between mom and daryl and
magnus because
yeah
this one could swing things at the top
for sure and nepo and by the way just
checking on the game between lanier
lanier dominguez pardon me vessel and
topolof
once again
we have a position that's really kind of
blowing up i don't even know how else to
describe it other than uh one of the
sharp sharp sharp sicilians where
blowing up not calculation not in
black's favor not in black's face
such a bishop on d4 okay rook's hanging
i moved the rook show me you move the
rook uh
i'm not i'm not waiting i really want to
play knight c so what if i go queen
f2
queen to f2
yeah targeting f6
and f7 and lf7 yeah both and actually my
main idea was to go b4 but that's
probably not the
yeah maybe b4 actually wins a piece
there is also noticing that the rook is
on h3 i mean
that had five you know and just
yeah i was gonna i was gonna play knight
c4 and i was going to make some
false statement
that i don't mind being an exchange down
after bishop f6
that i began to believe i did mine into
being an exchange down uh
whoa magnus down to his last three
minutes let's jump yeah let's jump this
magnus's game it's three minutes and my
media of nine minutes on the clock so
huge time difference in this one
queen takes ace x in response to rookie
and rook the d
well first of all the bishop's not on c5
the pawn's not not before but can i put
it right now yes
i wouldn't want to see the bishop
anchored bishop c5 rook rook b3 it would
be three just to
prevent
this bishop from being nicely esconced
on the c5 square b2b4 and then queen to
c6
how do we respond to that
bishop c5 repeat
queen to c6
c7 that's the score i want to get to
exactly
but then maybe you can create this rook
to d7 fortress and maybe that's why he
played rook to d8
well
for for me uh the move rook to d8 was
all about kind of keeping that deep on
under
a watchful eye you don't want it ever to
get to d7 right now there's a pin
uh along the sixth rank but uh
i was thinking you know you want to kind
of put your pieces maybe rook to d7 king
g7
uh sorry what is the time so you were
you were warning me that
that that that eight minutes was less
than three minutes
for both sides no no eight minutes
eight minutes and two minutes and 49
seconds for magnus yeah well but to be
fair it's not that mummy drove can make
a lot of progress immediately indeed if
you just put the rook on d7 with black
right try to dissolve it it's not like
you're running any serious risk of
losing or falling apart well
i'm i'm thinking that if we do go bishop
c5 and we do see rook b3
and for example if we do see a queen c6
king g7 we get some position like this
i'm not saying that this is a great play
for for for either side
at a certain moment when his king is all
nice and comfy
black starts to think about h5 and g4
and he starts to think hey look i'm
going to exchange up my rook on b3 might
actually be really really good
and
you know
maybe we've been a little here we go
queen a5 well actually i'm talking both
rooks
rook to
b8
okay
but this guy
right kind of allows bishop c5 b4 setup
that's the that's the dream once you get
the bishop c5 and b4
and he's going for it then the exchange
i think you're
you just you just know that the bishop
on c5 and the pawn on b4
the pawn on d6 pardon me are worth an
exchange whether it's advantage that's a
different question
um
cool uh sorry i wanted you to just check
a lot of things have changed by the way
guys
versus the bottle of
game yeah everything not very
consequential at least not up to this
point towards the standings but still a
very sharp game
knight to d7 and
first of all after queen to f2 can you
go back just one second how did he
defend everything
all of that is because there are so many
threats in the position so he played
rook to f8 okay
and white decided not to go for the
exchange with bishop to f6
he never had the chance
oh he played queen of two one move late
yes
well rook f8 and knight d7 stopped these
threats
a king b7 was quite the challenging move
i must say
looks very strange
to walk into a number of pins
whoa whoa whoa rook c8
okay bishop g2 is hanging sorry i beg
your pardon i was looking at bishop c5
and rook f7 but oh no i figured out what
it was we were looking at the position
but we thought it is white to move
the queen takes g5 king b1 but it was in
fact black to move it well i want no i
went i meant i went rookie eight yeah
yes i went through k8 and that's how how
we got into that hole
got it right so he went rook f8 instead
much superior move
and uh we reached this moment with
bishop h3
ooh uh
that's a scary looking
quite quite a few pins i think yeah like
crisscrosses and
pins on this and rook c7 and vessel and
says
please do your worst
um
f7 okay let me try rook takes f7 queen
takes f7 queen h5
is a little bit of a hit right mm-hmm um
i think black's in here with a shout
black's better already yeah
okay and perhaps you can even start with
queen to h5 leave the queen on f2 so
that you can target it with knight to e4
win a temple like that oh
oh oh
that's
that's pretty i like that question
hy force i think you're forcing rook to
h1
there is a a pesh key hanging here and
here so rook f1 and this is where you
like this uh
rambunctious explainable tempo
play with tempo and knight to g3 coming
this is starting to look really good for
black guys
remarkable okay we'll keep an eye on
this one i'm sorry that i have to just
uh uh go back to magnus sue magnus's
game because there is a pawn on d7
and by the way queen to h5 in that game
is on the board queen h5 magnus
under pressure what what's going on here
one minute and 50 seconds for magnus
wait a second after d7 that is a massive
pawn on d7 what's going on yeah well uh
i'm i'm looking at bishop
e7 bishop b6 ideas uh
can you bail out
rook to a8 bail out
some sort of a bailout situation uh wait
that's like sir
still
queen to c7 i think i have queens
yes queen c ones on
rook a8
again the time magnus getting nervous i
see yeah magnus is down to two once uh
one minute one minute one minute
under one minute and the decisions are
not
getting easier
either
absolutely but if you don't play rook 8
i mean don't
don't you just like i get married
for free right so you kind of have to
unless there is some specific i was uh
during the junior championships i was
taking the juniors to
task
for playing with the pieces
in front of their opponents when you see
three immediately
very quickly played and here i see the
world champion twiddling
with uh the pieces and the belongings
take on c3 and go king f7 king e6 magnus
you
wait queen f7 leaving the queen
queen f7 very quickly too
queen d3 i'm i'm starting to
get really uncomfortable if i'm magnus
hang on a second rook ba troop b7 is he
on time to do that
well because if he is
he's picking up the d7 pawn and he's
done it he's done it he said
who's and we do have a draw between draw
for wesley wesley not happy with the the
way he handled the white pieces there
but back
to magnus and again this move rook b8
threatens rook b7
so what if i stop you from doing that
queen queen a6
but isn't it
hanging then f6 is saying
yeah f6 is hanging which is which is sad
news very very sadness not but i will
have to take i'm afraid yes sir i'll
have to take on these services 10
seconds left for magnus on the clock
right right king g7
he has to make a move guys g7 queen cc
c7 rook d7 queen d7
6 6 and i've got a feel that that oh
this is not good news for him you might
actually lose this one with black easy
easy this is not good news
easily
with such a king
exposed king and always he has 10
seconds on the clock guys you end up not
blundering here i mean probably there is
no chance right there's always going to
be something yeah rookie eight already
he gives me another point gives up g5
yeah let me take that one as well and
queen g67 and of course well the nice
thing about losing the pawn on g5 is you
don't blunder it anymore i mean it's
gone
you don't have to worry about holding on
to it
and uh well a two result game as far as
i'm concerned this bishop
uh and two pawns versus the rook with an
exposed king
shaq is in no danger of losing this and
absolutely lots of clock time for him
five minutes for shaq yeah
he's he the world champion is definitely
going to be in trouble okay
throwing in e4
b4 i want to see a double h thing yeah
oh b4 queen a one check yeah b4 he has a
couple of chances
but then i can play f4
and uh
i don't know that looks like a good
alternative oh also bishop d4 b4
yeah queen would probably go to g6 in
that case and you can go four maybe the
same as before like you're taking maybe
a slight amount of risk and leaving
black with the past pawn but you're
getting such a beautiful pawn formation
on the king side how about
uh i can take oh if i take on e4
queen b2 bishop d4
you can check me on b1 b4 is on the b4
is on the board okay makes sense just
again um
anchor the bishop learn to keep your
pieces
defended protect your pieces to me the
idea of bishop to d4 followed by f4 was
the most uh potent in the position okay
also because you have uh bishop to c3
followed by queen to d4 creating that
deadly battery
along the way exactly right now you
don't have that on tap anymore but yeah
i'm i think he wanted to play f4 and
king h2 and just
unhurriedly
uh stick his
safety right right b5 b6 maybe also
awesome
um get the point to be big moment here
queen g6
miro your first yeah as why what are you
striving for
and obviously i'm playing for a win i
mean there's no questions no question
asked f4
by the way shaq also getting a little
nervous he ate queenie two okay
sidestepping look d3
and rook dropped it on dc here's the d3
nevertheless right
there's some checks from a2 if needed
correct
why not i like it
by the way what looked to be a very
hard-fought game between
vessel and topolof who was black against
lanier dominguez ended in a draw
so we are left with oh okay this round
it's three draws we are left with
perugia against uh la graf which okay
a couple of times already shifted in
evaluation and this game between federal
queen wisconsin
queen a8 threatening i see the checkmate
threat that's right the queen eight
no queen g3
i think you might mate me first yeah
queen she treats but like even if it
works
you can't really play it
you don't believe it queen a8 but either
way that's a very powerful looking move
this thread of mate also tickling the
pawn on
e4
geometrically not even sure what black's
going to play
exactly h6 and run and pray you know
i don't know you might
you're oh
check queen a7 check what screen a7
well queen f7 is another is an obvious
question right right what what's this
end game uh i'm not sure there's an
ending in this bishop d4 check for check
oh well
can we can we show this one yeah like
queen f7 bishop d4 check and if the king
goes to g6 we have the
very visual move f5
yeah and queen f5 and g4 check yeah g4
check is nice
forks the queen and the king
so uh magnus in trouble
the direct check
looks to be incredibly powerful and what
does the engine say about them apples uh
christian well right now after kingdom
g8 which was by the way played
uh it seems like white is just taking
over
literally winning wait a second king g8
it was terrible
that's what we were trying to achieve
yeah so the queen was on a8 and so on
yes
so that's what you're trying to achieve
so basically with the tempo to spec he's
trying to go towards the center right i
think king to f7 and king to e6 this is
what we have right now g4 wow
g4 okay that is uh
he doesn't even he doesn't even go queen
fa check he just goes
to play f5
and uh meet you
and shaq apparently won his game
unfortunately we'd lost we don't know if
it was on time or
it might have been on time yeah it looks
like g4 was the last move in the
position so magnus loses his first game
in this tournament what a big result
there was some
i think we think it was on time by the
way just to confirm and i think mvl well
let's jump to that pretty much took over
this game
because change up
right now against early
early
uh
early year
we thought ferugia was for choice but
not anymore not anymore anymore mbl is
uh yells winning
that's just a very controlling rook that
pawn is not going anywhere anytime soon
and i'm going to start picking up your
pawns bishop takes h4 bishop
what what does it do to the tournament
standings uh
through the tournament standings after
upside down is what it what happened
was not tied for the third right so it
was furuja and west wesley
wesley made it
will be pushed back clear
knight to c2 but what do you do against
a4 yeah i think he wants to go king c3
king b3 to try to
kick the rook away from the back
the rooks belong behind past bombs
kick the rook
away from the pass
from being behind the passport
yeah it's still very sharp i have to say
yeah uh yeah i
i
won whoa
honestly
the first choice
it really didn't uh register that that
was happening so bishop e3 in order to
be able to
push the pawn yeah
this is surprising to picture e3 makes a
strong impression right
but you didn't really need the g5 pawn
you need to put the bishop
on g3 and go h4 as black
oh by the way did you see how he's kind
of like yeah disgusting like a magnusi
style yeah like ah
rook b5 wait a second so so
goes to a7 but yes are we talking like
taking on g5
a7
yeah yeah a7 and exactly the position i
had in mind uh a7 rook a5 black carbon
oh you want to play your room
you're 100 safe
and you're trying to
i don't know i i don't think he got the
best yeah it could be just a draw yeah i
felt he had much something much better
than that yeah yeah he cashed in his
chips too soon i think well actually it
turns out we're in in a table-based
territory it is a draw yeah it is a draw
well and it's not like exclusively only
moves for white so basically this setup
has to be a draw but of course and we
will keep trying of course you have to
say it's still
it's still possible to misplay with
white easily easily two pawns uh
but okay a little shaky there with uh
could you could i ask the times it's not
easy for me to see 45 55 seconds right
now for
foreign a couple of minutes for mvl
by the way that and in day one we saw a
huge number of decisive games things are
settling down a bit i think the players
are getting used to
the stage which actually is very very
beautiful i must say as well as the time
okay control g6 okay that's that's an
interesting that's an interesting thing
yeah inviting knight g5 yeah
yeah but how does he get past the g5
square right
for the time being it's not clear at all
i mean uh
we do have uh the g5 square well
controlled
okay
and just to remind everybody that we do
have uh
how do i put it
challenger or do i say
[Music]
of the world championship marriage but
this time it won't be they're both
challenges right right
kind of equal in their rights
[Laughter]
but uh our finalists are waiting
can this be
and
rook to g4 king h6 just forces matters
because then i have knight g5 or knight
right
let's see
let's see i'm not so sure i thought like
having the king on h3 and or g3 right
and just pretty simple playing for for
the fortress but but yeah once again if
king h6
forces
yeah then it's much more forcing because
knight g5 check well it's like
you know apparently but both are fine
it's just a matter of taste rook c a
rooksy a disturbing the bishop for the
time being no king takes
g66 it's supposed to be
unless uh unless the alternatives are
really bad what is this
why not bishop f6 bishop six rook cafe
perhaps like defaulting yeah he is
actually going for it okay let's maybe
including a check maybe including g5
knight g5 check and then king two king
five
yeah no no no no king e5 yes nice knight
f7 check take my rook that's okay
no
yes of course e5 you take the rook i'm
not i'm not sure if you catch the pawn
yeah
king knight f7 king f4
and now you take on h5 you don't take
the rook but you i take the rook yes and
i go knight e6 check easy draw
four knight g5 yeah
okay it was a draw at the end
uh uh a friendly draw between two french
grand masters
that's easy no problem and now uh we
we are hopeful
that uh
grandmaster ding liran will join us and
there he is
welcome welcome welcome
nice to have you on the show
how are you
uh good
good
in barcelona
you're in barcelona
i see uh
tell us your thoughts what what what do
you think about what's going on with
magnus and
your new elevated position mr
dingleren
well this is my eighth interview
[Laughter]
yeah
three
uh
in china no three all sides of china is
five in china ah well we wanted to be
the last
uh i think so
and what have you been saying to the
people
oh well
yeah i didn't expect his decisions
but it's understandable
since
uh it's clear he
he makes some motivations to defend
another titles
um also the crown had
gave him maybe too much pleasure and the
responsibilities had to handle with
so he preferred to enjoy playing
chess other than suffering
nicely put
and do you feel
that
you will be suffering having to play a
million dollar world championship match
uh since it's my first time to fight for
the world championship
so
there's a lot of fresh air i can breathe
and yes the everything new
and
still there are a long time
to go
um for the
world championship
thing
first of all congratulations what are
the first steps right now you're in this
position uh the match maybe is a year
away from now how are you going to put
together your preparation plan what is
next what is the next step for dingley
rep
[Music]
maybe the
the special preparation will come just
before the tournament i i think i guess
the best way for me is just to
keep it normal
and as usual
and
do what i do
uh
in europe
so
just before the tournament i will do
some special
preparation just according to the
specific player and for the openings but
before that i think the most important
thing is to improve your general strings
are you going to put together a team of
seconds right now do you have any
names in mind and if you don't want to
answer that question you feel like it's
revealing too much don't worry about it
yes i have
one or two names
yeah
yeah and he's
close to me
but i don't think it's the most
important thing
what is the feeling like in china
are they proud
that
you will be competing for the world
championship you will be the first
chinese man
to compete in the open championship you
have already many world champions
in the ladies game
you'll be the first male uh what is the
feeling like in china
yeah we have many women world
championship
and also many uh teams
championship but
we don't have any um male challengers
for the world crown so
yes
they are very excited about the
possibilities
and i think when i get back to china
they will
talk to me
more seriously and
they will try to help me absolutely very
very exciting
times uh miro any questions for our
finalists yeah well yeah i had a lot but
somehow i don't don't even know what to
say yeah
uh it is a controversial one because of
course like magnus stepping away made
you to play the match but uh would you
agree that it's a little bit sad for
let's say for a chess world that the
champion and you know number one uh
rated player that he kind of steps away
from the match
yes since
i also understand his decisions
you know sometimes uh
early player is not so
um
object of of mistake about the
world championship and even the future
of chess
like this
maybe
sometimes
i also feel that
difficult to find the right words uh
ding we want to thank you so very much
for taking time out of your day and
joining us and sharing your thoughts but
it's a dream come true for you
so we're going to wish you a lot of
success yeah as a
world championship match finalist
you thank you very much thank you very
much
and there you have it miro uh
the first
chinese
challenger finalist in the world
championship many many ladies have won
the championship many chinese ladies
but this is a big moment for china
right
i fail i feel it too
and
as we uh take our break uh we asked the
players uh in zagreb what they think
about changing the format of the world
championship and these were their
answers we'll see on the other side of
the break for our final round of the day
[Music]
if you had to change the format of the
world championship finals between two
players what would your format look like
oh if i ever got there i don't think i'd
care too much about the formula i'd just
be happy to get there but
i haven't i don't have too many specific
thoughts on the on the
form that i would say from my personal
side
i think the current form of this all
right i heard a new proposal of holding
a match in several sets so three sets of
four games which sounds interesting as
well because then
you might keep the match interesting
like you lose one set but then you can
win another set and it
keeps it interesting so i heard that
carlson will not play unless
like playing conditions change like the
format so i hope they might change it
into something you like so you'll play
of course that's what i like to see
no i don't i simply don't think it
exists
because
there's always maybe some
format that favors
some of the players and the others are
better in rapid someone is better in
knockouts other than round robin so i
don't think it exists but
well the main thing is i guess is once
it starts you can't make changes so that
that i believe that's the it's because
it's it's been in the history it's
happened many times and i don't think
it's a good idea so
i believe it's only a good idea to
change to make changes after it's over
with the cycle i am not sure it's very
good to change
this requirement in last time a last
moment
i think
magnus he played very good match against
jan in
in last format but he played not very
good much against fabiano and the
kayaking
i think for him it's a little bit boring
to play in same format
well i think a match is necessary like
you kind of have to beat the
world champion in
in a match in order to become one
yourself
uh the tradition has always been
classical games right at least 12. it
used to be 24 it to be longer many years
ago i just
want to see classical chess i think it's
the most important
time control
so shortening it doesn't
make much sense to me
if you
if the score is tight after that then
you keep going on the classical i just
don't think mixing shorter time control
makes that much sense but
we'll see it's it's more attractive also
to the fans who have blitz and rapid but
personally to me i like classical yes i
am probably
everybody agrees that maybe it should be
a little bit
faster
so
there are a lot of formats that could be
more interesting but it should be
discussed of course with the video so
i think it's not very bad the format
that we have now but i think it could be
more better and entertaining also
it's hard to give it definitive answers
but
first of all i think uh
sad's idea
best of three sets or best of five sets
it sounds like a great idea in the sense
that there wouldn't be
any game without stakes
i haven't thought about that because i'm
still
quite the longer
and far away from the playing the world
championship match but uh
to be honest i don't think there's
anything wrong with the current format
if you want to see who is the best
player in the world it has to be
reasonably long match of classical chess
i don't believe too much in
other formats in terms of rabbit or
blitz for
for the title because
i think the best player in chassis is
the best player in classical chess not
so much in
in rabbit and blitz i really like the
classical forward because i think we
have some safer championships for
uh rabbits and for blitz and i don't
really think it's it's a good idea to
mix up but uh for sure it's
i think it's wrong to change the rules
like in the middle of a cycle so this
has to be discussed let's say right
after
i don't know let's say right after the
mesh or something yeah but then we at
the very beginning of the new cycle so
we make sure that
we you know
we play to qualify and we play okay the
match
uh with some same regulations same you
know same time control same
same rules like sofiano rules and so on
that's
that's obviously a good question because
uh
i know time
time is now different
you know comparing to what was like okay
let's say 100 years ago and maybe we
really need to seek for the new format
but this is
i would say that we have like
it's more than
i mean almost 150 years tradition of
holding classical nations and
uh i think
this is quite priceless i don't know
what the ideal
setup for the
world championship match is
i think there are
a lot of formats that could be tried
but
as i've said for for many years i think
the one that we have now is
um is one of one of the worst when when
it comes to
[Music]
you know selecting
the best player um
specifically i would say that
there are
two too few games um
also it's kind of
kind of too easy to
to defend when you have so long to
to to prepare and um
i think it's
really all set up to decrease the
chances that the best player
wins
so i in general i would say
more games
less time would be
would be better
definitely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super
rapid and blitz in zagreb croatia here
are our standings mira we just witnessed
the world championship world champion
losing
against a match yeah losing a game
that's very incredible
right uh indeed after bleak games with
white magnus just lost his black against
chakriermann yarrow which puts chakriar
in thai for the third place i see that
yeah so first place is shared ali reza
fi ruja and wesley
and uh for this round six and our final
a game of the day
who do we have who's our marquee
matchups yeah so mvl plays against
savage nepal against one forest topalov
wesley saw something maybe even with the
black pieces wesley can hope for
something carlson will face dominguez
and finruja will play mommy the arab
that's a really interesting game yeah
that feels like uh a very very nice game
to keep our eye on and i believe that
again farouza should be the one with the
seven points not mvl in that particular
uh matchup is again we do have wesley so
and farouza tied for first
and uh as we have a
uh always an
open forum to our viewers we have a
question from social media
from a twitcher twitch user ripper
yeah are they refusing the chairs from
the candidates these are the same ikea
marcus chairs
uh i have no idea what's your
perspective on that one i didn't pay
attention i wasn't either uh i thought
that uh the staging of the candidates by
the way big shout out to the organizers
there i just thought that the the palace
the palacio that they played in was just
gorgeous
just the the
photos the videos everything about the
the staging look good
and here in zagreb it looks like the
stage is really beautiful i saw
the audience full of people
they come out in force in croatia they
love their chess
yeah have you ever gotten a chance to
play in croatia in croatian no i don't
think i visited croatia strangely enough
it's kind of a long spontaneous like
europe map which i failed almost yeah
even some exotic countries but
i played in inner zonal in zagreb
absolutely and uh i i enjoyed visiting
the city that
that was a very nice country for chess
a deep history i want to say
as you see the players getting started
again this is our third and final round
of uh
the rapids as the games are underway we
see nepo versus jordan ven forrest also
a big matchup only because jordan has
been playing so exceptionally
successfully so far
and he missed a big chance in the last
game
against ivan starage truly that was a
funny
draw at the very end i must say no he
surely must have consulted with an
engine after the game and realized the
fact that he could have continued the
game and just be completely crushing in
that final position will that affect him
in this matchup against nepo yeah
as we see once again the joko piano and
again it's just remarkable how this
centuries-old opening that
well i think in the 80s and 90s the
feeling was it was played out
that there was no reason to go and
revisit these lines and we were all
stunned when
gary played the scotch
we thought that too was played out but
now
it's a new life is being uh breathed
into uh both of these
openings and defenses rook e1
yeah well this d75 the plan was like
postponing uh the movement of the d-pawn
to castle first and then to go d5 in one
go
uh
i think it was
like debated a lot a few years back and
then for no particular reason it was
the one that would be that would be
known to me right they stopped yeah and
it's always like that on a very high
level that some opening
system or sometimes even the big opening
like the petrol for instance
remember like i don't know kramnik times
like everyone would play the petrov
peter lake i mean there it was very and
then like you said the vanish that the
fashion just changed yeah and we don't
know what was wrong with the petrol and
now the guys are kind of
reviving really
and he happens to be like nothing wrong
with the petrol it's just that you know
the fashion passes to something else
right so it might as well just all these
trends burn themselves out
and then they come back that's basically
what all these top players are playing
them and then they get bored because
they don't want to repeat the same lines
either they don't want to be sitting
ducks or they don't want to look like
sitting ducks at the top level and then
they just go away shy away from those
trends and then come back years later
this is what's happening tell us what is
happening uh
theoretically wise in the position
between a nepo and jordan vin forrest it
seems to me if black just plays the move
d5 it never gets punished in other words
so if you never take the pawn on e5 yeah
no no no it does seem like actually this
move bishop to e6 might have been um a a
very
simple wrinkle in the position bishop to
g4 is by far
the main line bishop e6 only two games
have been played in this position
uh two big games by the way at least one
of them is kramnik versus anand from
2018 and that might have surprised
[Laughter]
and now we have a4 and a bishop to b6
this one is going to be quite an
interesting one a big theoretical battle
between these two players knight to a3
but not as much is going to happen but
take a look at what's happening in
magnus's game magnus was like okay in
the first three games with the white
pieces i got absolutely nothing out of
the opening by playing main lines let's
try to switch things up a little bit
especially against a territion like
dominguez and he did that by starting
with one g3 okay one g3 c5 bishop to g2
knight to c6 and now we're seeing a
double fiance set up for magnus which is
clearly signaling the fact that okay
this is it i'm trying to avoid theory i
just want to play a game i don't want to
see you blitzing out your first 20 moves
let's just play a game of chess and this
is what we're having right now
b2b3
had magnus played the move e2 e4 by the
way it was kind of funny that i've seen
been seeing magnus playing this uh bod
vinnick triangle system
with e2 e4 favorite of mine uh knight
b2 b3 knight f6 there was a pause
because i could understand that
well
sometimes think about it you go bishop
takes c3 on those rare occasions and i
can tell you
that players like olf anderson for one
know how to neutralize
the long diagonal themselves by playing
for b6 uh lanier shied away from that he
just played knight f6 bishop b2
castles and we'll keep an eye on this
one let's go to another game uh one of
our leaders wesley sowe versus vessel
and topalov vessel and topple off with
the white pieces
it starts as an english but then it just
looks like a sicilian doesn't it yeah
reverses
sicilian
although i must say he hasn't yet played
the move d6 d5
um your thoughts on this one mira
well
i think it's just one of those you know
one of those systems where white wants
to
play yeah i want to play i don't want
any anything forced yeah i'm not asking
for any kind of advantage yeah we'll
postpone the battle to
30 or so
knight h7 okay always watch out for
these
tricky trappy moves f5 and pardon me e4
f5 and e4 or just simply e4 right away
uh keep keep an eye on those moves yeah
c3 seems to be yeah kind of logical
move knight h
is he playing for a fight i assume so he
made
he made room for it at least
whether it's good or not we'll keep an
eye on that one and let's finally go to
shaq because
you do you have this as a sportsman
let's face it shaq just had a huge
victory he beat the world champion you
know like
do you go yay and then fall flat on your
face because
i mean like you get over excited with
your previous results yeah sometimes
as a sportsman yeah right yeah i think
it does yeah one of your best moments is
followed by one of my more
yeah very catastrophic uh so what do you
think is going to happen between
farouzia
and shaq shark is not probably not that
type of a guy because first of all i
mean he had these moments
he's enjoyed a few uh victories you
might say right and maybe
it's the opposite that he's kind of
gonna be gaining the pace you know
feeling like uh that was good one more
please yeah we'll take another
i think that's definitely the trend for
shaq i mean let's not forget how he
started this tournament he started with
a loss a big loss against jordan van
forest and then in the second game
i believe it was against the croatian
yvonne sarri he was completely lost yeah
and he saved that rook's end game after
that it felt like he gained another life
in the tournament and won his final game
uh
defended accurately against topalov in
what it was i mean it cannot even uh be
overstated he was completely losing
against apollo in the first game of
today's matches and then one against
magnus he's the trend for this man is
definitely positive right now as we
started our broadcast uh
christian highlighted the two young
players in the event uh farouja and
jordan van fors 36 years old is that a
peak
a period for you or do you think shaq
has several more years to go before ep
definitely has several more years but
i mean
like playing a very very high level but
uh his 2800 status of the past
yeah that that's not easy to say yeah
yeah
because we were having these
conversations to
the ideal age for chess player 31 of
magnus today yeah well it seems that it
kind of shifted towards the lower mark
yes
30 i would i would call that like
they're
learning
very early right they consume a lot of
information now with all the computers
database and so on and quite possibly
like in in professional physical sports
like if someone goes to basketball court
and he's 35 years of age what do you say
yeah very exactly please unless your
name is lebron james unless your name is
lebron so
there are always some exceptions right
right the nolan ryan ryans of the world
this was a baseball pitcher but uh a
long lived obviously a baseball pitcher
but i always thought
20 to 36
for me those were the prime
career ages
for chess players so for me i still see
magnus i was thinking magnus would be
there for this cycle and another and
another and then
you know uh the farouz is the but that's
too big of a window uh yeah yeah it's a
bit more specific is it 31 to 33 give me
a three-year window
i don't know
first of all how old are you how old are
you
i got to know my audience
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me think
uh by a weird coincidence the highest
rating i had was when i was 31.
ah
31 yeah i don't even know what the
highest rate rating i had uh by the way
uh back to the game ali reads he just
played b4b5 a very very standard
idea
to weaken this pawn on c6 however before
he did that he first put his queen on d2
which is
not in keeping with the strategy of
making a weakness on on c6 normally
speaking the queen would go to a4 but
now
is it time that we should just take take
and play rook b1 bishop a3
uh
rook b1 immediately by the way he won
immediately okay okay
so excuse me
i don't know if it makes any difference
because i thought d5 nevertheless yeah
and then you probably take c6 first
before taking on d5 by the way i really
attributed
it was a particular game of godakomski
that got a play just
like a shared genius where he put his
bishop on g8 which is so rare
and his king was really safe we were
talking yesterday with the bishop on f8
and how you know this traditional
classical
uh
who was throwing i think it was shaq
where it was just throwing everything
yeah at the
forest's position and didn't break
through
uh but the bishop on g8 just you shifted
one file over uh christian um what games
uh have caught your eye well i was
definitely looking at the game of the
world champion magnus carlson versus
dominguez because a lot of things have
happened we've seen at this position and
he decided to jump with the knight to h3
not to the usual f3 square now this
signals the fact that the battle is
going to be for the d5 square i'm going
to go knight to f4 potentially support
h4 h5 but keep control of the d5 square
very important uh square in the center
and dominguez said no the battle starts
right now i'm going to go d5 immediately
take advantage of the fact that your
knight is on h3 and we got to this
position
right now very intriguing uh situation
the bishop h3 obviously very powerful up
to this point keeping the king in check
you cannot castle uh at the moment so
that's going to inhibit white's movement
a little bit now how do you assess this
position i understand white has clear
targets on the queen side these pawns
are going to be under attack very soon
rook to c1 is coming followed by queen
to c2 the king is a bit weak the way i
see it but how do we control the
position as black bishop to d4 seems to
be preferred by the engine and right now
it is dominguez who is taking a pretty
significant thing only 20 minutes on the
clock against 21 for magnus so let's
take a look at this game try to analyze
the position and try to understand what
the nuances where the nuances lie
well there i mean it's clear to me that
black's pawn structure on the queen size
have been totally ruined
in order to keep white's king in the
center so
it's this dynamic versus static right so
these static weakness you're lost on the
queen side just lost end of story unless
you get wonderful counter play against
white's king queen d5
bishop d4 you you you get you
some dynamic chances
but
one of the things i i found out about
these top grand masters they're very
very good at neutralizing your play you
know they they find these ways of taking
your attack away neutralizing dynamics
and then winning on positional exactly
exactly so
if you play a move like bishop d4 and uh
that's a decent move i can imagine rook
c1 queen
and again you've got to play
yeah these types of moves queen d5
where
you're you're really banking on
something good happening against
the the king side um we'll keep an eye
on that one but i have to turn our
attention to nepo's game for a minute
because jordan van forest has just
played a move
that to my eyes says
i'm seizing the initiative i just don't
know what you're doing
i'm going to play the move knight
on a d5 to f4
and
i'm hitting d3 and i'm looking looking
looking
meryl
clear the cobwebs here
what am i doing is right
no but you know why i'm kind of pausing
and laughing at the same time because it
might be one of those instances where
jan plays quickly up to the point where
he starts thinking in the position where
he basically has only move to capture on
e5 right but it's too late to think
right could this be right because
95 which is yeah it looks a trash
you've got to defend yeah
knight takes back perhaps yeah exactly
and if knight takes i was a little
bishop
yeah maybe queen g5 immediately maybe
you take on b3 go queen g5 yeah i was a
little bit thinking queen f7 check
otherwise seven checking girls and g3
but if i go queen g5 yeah if you go
start with queen g5 right and i'm
threatening mate
i've got an issue
yeah i will have to play g3 and bishop
takes yeah yeah you take queen takes
takes everything takes on f4 and i hate
it
yeah i despise uh this type of thing
where i take stakes on f4 even though b7
is hanging maybe it's not that clear to
be honest
i don't believe white is better here but
he's not in such a trouble i don't know
uh in these major major endings where
there's a queen and rook on the board
oftentimes i just feel it's about king
position and who has a safe king
and
this is not the same game
isn't it
it was queen on a
long diagonal
such a bad kill
i don't know
not that i like this position no it's
not everybody's uh cup of tea uh but for
for my taste uh christian this move
knight f4 by
by jordan vin forrest is saying
what kind of challenger are you i'm
going after your after you're king
what's going on well it's definitely
jordan who won uh the opening battle in
this one let's not forget jordan was an
integral part of magnus's team in
preparation for this match against ian
nepomnyashi so he definitely has some
residual knowledge from that match every
player on a challenger or a world
champions team is tasked with certain
openings to look at maybe who knows
maybe this was one of jordan's uh
situations in which he had to look at
the joko piano and come up with ideas
and this is what he's showcasing right
now with this idea bishop to e6 a very
nuanced wrinkle instead of that move
bishop to g4 which was by far the
mainline 200 plus games bishop to e6
take it easy and it seems like it was uh
quite surprising for the challenger
young napoleon right now after knight to
f4 the line that you guys showed was the
perfect line in the position with a
slight advantage for black at the end
but nothing spectacular maybe like a
zero minus minus
0.5 minus 0.4 something along those
lines nothing spectacular in that one
but it's not easy to go knight 85 and in
fact he did not do it he played the move
rook to e3 defending uh the bishop on
the pawn on d3 at the same time this
allows black with the move queen to f6
to stabilize the position right rook a
to d8 is going to come
on in the board i'm starting really
starting to like black's chances right
now i see moves recommended by the
engine not you cannot take on e5 anymore
because after bishop takes b3 you're
just simply going to lose a piece knight
takes e5 and rook takes c5
so you have to start getting ready to
attack the pawn on e5 with the move
queen to f1 not an easy move to see not
an easy move to make unless you know the
specifics of at this position definitely
one that i'm keeping my eyes on guys
very nice queen f6 and rook e3 by the
way big shout out to our grandchild
chess tour executive michael kortakowski
as he celebrates his birthday you see
right there 40 years young remarkable
it looks so good
and of course a a very key part of the
whole grand chess tour and uh that it
uh
making more sponsorships and our
standings by the way of our grandchild
tour as we haven't got this particular
graphic in oh that's a nice graphic with
all the money highlighting yes yes
that's what it's all about these guys
fight really hard and they're deserving
of everything that they earn you see
their
their big tournament the winner levon
aronian
ninety thousand
yeah and then
wesley's second fabiano's third
and
yeah well maxine uh doing very brave
yeah it's kind of a funny thing because
you see fabiano
with 13 grand chess tour points very
happy 46 000 and maxine the vaccine said
keep your 13 grandchester
i'll take you 77 000. it price money now
that's always reflected yeah
and the the rules are of course that the
there's the um classical tournaments of
bucharest and sinkfield everybody has to
play in those but then there are the
three rapid and blitz two of the three
and that is why fabi for example is not
in this uh
tournament by the way rookie one night
f4
just a second yes so we are back to
nepo's game against one for us right
i just was uh sorry i was just uh going
through
the whole list and it looked like a
repetition but maybe not no i don't know
yeah yeah what's going on knight f4
rookie three fc he went queen of six and
92.
all right and bishop c2 definitely not
looking like a repetition right now no
but uh is i stabilized i might as well
start controlling even more squares in
the position so let's go h5 h4 right oh
h4 well i'm looking at this move queen
to g5 or queen to g6 in the future
putting some pressure on g2 but you
always have rook to g3 right exactly the
way i can try to soften up maybe even
the light squares is by creating some
weaknesses h5 h5h4h3 if you allow me to
also control the g3 square
intriguing uh
an approach of advancing the pawns i
would
in such positions my approach would be
to try to force my opponent to create
some weaknesses
so i would find my
myself attracted to the move bishop to
d5
and hoping to entice uh for example
knight e4 like i don't know if this is
the right move is on the board uh queen
to e6 and then i start thinking
oh i'm going to play yeah
and f5 i create some weaknesses around
white's king you know just trying to
mess up the pawn shield a bit if you
play g3 okay
i might settle in for knight h3 we do
have bishop d5 on the board but what you
mentioned there christian this idea of
h5h4
you know you the more you think about it
it's kind of compelling right because
you take away
if you don't have the move rook g3
queen g6 is going to hurt absolutely
right on 94 you have queen h6 right yes
that's another reason yes yeah and uh
five ninety-four jager queen h6 and then
the knight and c4 is hanging and h4 is
still in the cards exactly bishop d5
definitely seems very natural and
putting a lot of pressure right now on
white do you want to play the move f3
and
one of my least favorite exactly to be
honest
at the same time black doesn't have the
dark square bishop so you might as well
try to take advantage of that by
solidifying your pawn uh structure on
the king side like that especially that
soft spot the g2 square that's the big
one exactly we see rook to g3 but
doesn't that invite maybe h5h4
no
no we're talking about that
that that's with tempo i always like uh
ben feingold i think uh grand master ben
finding gold uh that's really really fun
streams i i like a sense of humor but
but uh
tongue-in-cheek he would say always play
f2 f3 when you get the chance usually
it's
never played
never play f6
never that's that's his thing never play
f6 or f3 there you go so i think he's
right in this guy he's got a point right
by the way i mean no seriously christian
that's not a joke after rook g3
um
h5 really looked much more he went
which makes some sense as well well he
he does want to tickle the rook
with knight f5 and he's done it 93
knight five three knight f5 so the
trading
looks
i'm telling you domino
jordan has been playing
at least these first
five and a half games
very impressively i mean
he's handling the 2700s
and 800 players pretty convincingly he's
showing that he really belongs it
doesn't look like he was 2700 as well
right now he dropped a little bit right
but he's uh poised to make another push
and potentially get over 2700 he's been
doing a lot of training he's been uh
preparing the best in in in the world
getting exposed to a lot of chess so
maybe this is it this is his moment to
break through yeah
well i can tell you uh when magnus
carlsen
invites you to his team
it's saying something right i mean yeah
i mean
uh so at night five uh it looks to me
like uh jordan is uh is enjoying his
position in nepo
little not so much not so much not so
much yeah well uh this 97 knight f5 one
more thing to add please you know it's
not only like a good move
it's a
move which comes from a man of culture
because the only kind of real problem
you have in all those joko pianos is the
fact that the knight on c6 is restricted
by the c3 pawn
so you have like all the pieces all the
other pieces easily joining the game and
so on but the knight on c6 is always a
problem and same goes for the rui lopez
right right it's very tempting to go
knight e7 knight g6 sometimes on 97
knight to 5 in this case yeah i was
always impressed when this kramnik
maneuver of knight e7 to g6 he's done it
in a number of different settings but
you're absolutely right you take the
knight on c6 that doesn't have a the
brightest future
redeploy it to the fi square with a gain
of tempo you're kind of bringing it into
the attack and having some fun did he
take on d5 or did he take on he took on
f5 he did take on f5 so
a trade that will
very much favor black i want to say the
knight on c6
not playing
it was subject of the attack of the
pawns coming down the board b4 b5 right
so it makes sense like this
isn't it
isn't it an ugly move
except he wants to follow it up
immediately with d4 and
i have a question regarding that so
bishop
take it
doesn't look bad at all take it excuse
me about take and then e4 at the end yes
how how bad is that for uh for y i
wanted to ask exactly the same questions
takes take takes and e4
and the whole point is we are
threatening queen g yeah we always have
this queen g5 check that's important
and now the question did looking good
did
pardon me did nepo
miss this tactic because if we go back
bishop c6 or bishop e6 we can understand
why yeah it's like we would be
happy still was not convinced because
there is 92 in this position i think he
missed it guys and it's like
yeah he missed it because he left
he also left yeah uh-huh
and you're gonna do it and that takes g2
just kills him on the spot bishop g2 and
he lives from the board he's like okay i
don't want i don't want any emotion
seriously did i pick young ni punch my
candidate for winning the event good
people christian i we've been discussing
this for for for quite some time okay
we need some new blood i mean alejandro
is too easy
uh our apologies to
mvl and ivan saurage we didn't
we didn't have a chance
we were looking a bishop takes g2 and we
got stuck
guess what bishop takes g2 by jordan on
the board
and uh
yeah sorry show us a fair square draw it
looks like perhaps we can see nepo's
reaction when he comes on from the board
at the board or he he knows he's created
a disaster
when he left but isn't this just simply
over like yeah you have anything else
basically that's what it comes down to
right
yeah when the moment i saw him reaching
for a c4 pawn i thought this had
disaster written all over at miro i just
did
i didn't like what nepo was doing and
bishop cheese
and that's a wake up a shake of the head
from nepo when he comes back you're
looking for the shake of that i want to
see the shake of the head
here we go we're about to see it
no there won't be no shakers
not yet okay give it a couple of years
no real life let's go let's i think he
realized already that yeah okay i've
played c4 i've landed and give it a
couple of moves guys
really
the shake of the head
ah
you know your man look at you christian
no that's that's more or less like a
neutral shake of head i want to see a
disappointment the real one
the real one yes
okay uh but take us through this bishop
g2 knight g2 e
move but guys we we analyzed this uh
queen g5 i know yeah there is no myth
whatsoever e4
how do you get out of this d4 rook d4
you still can't prevent it headshot five
yeah so you're basically losing the
knight as
well and the whole point is the
desirable knight takes or rook takes is
walking into a very
very nasty queen g5
but even if you go d4 and then i take
only four with the rook do you have any
way to stop me from going queen g5 and
picking up your uh a full piece no
uh it's terrible it really is terrible
uh
we have been seeing some
uh say oops excuse me that was a a mouse
that we have been there there is a shake
of head guys i said did we see it i saw
it oh darn it i was uh it came i was
analyzing rook and bishop versus queen
uh
no
terrible no terrible not even
not even worthy of consideration
king h1
takes and rookie two
we think this is busted let's just check
in on magnus because he was playing
against lanier dominguez and that was
the
static
weaknesses versus the dynamic play we
left it
bishop d4 rook to e5 rook g1
magnus said give me
the pawn
never play f3
uh
i don't know but this looks like a
really really healthy
extra pawn uh queen d2 king f2 and uh
that not only am i pawn up but i'm
feeling good hold on queen
that's what i'm looking at
okay that is actually
so it's i'd like to move right rook
takes c4 to start with maybe this is how
we do it i think i think with the deep
one right take was the depo and i was
kind of thinking maybe like e5 a5 and
just to play this position so i do have
a bit of a center you know true so maybe
some compensation once again queen h3
being a mate also
but now i can go king to f2 right yeah
right yeah i agree like it's not uh it's
not like a full compensation even though
yeah queen h3
okay challenge the rook to h1
yeah okay you're looking down
but i mean white still has a lot of work
only because he's got some issue and
this is what i think you were expecting
christian the pain the pain
it's all about
exactly
uh what's for dinner mom
[Laughter]
yeah yeah this was not that was not a
good look yeah uh
the moment you actually look back back
at your life yeah exactly what did i do
to deserve this oh that's wrong where is
it um okay so this one wesley so again
we've got a wesley uh again he's this
very quiet
what is he doing in this game wasn't
that quiet yeah it was actually some
english we saw the 987
and
things
have definitely changed a great deal
what is this
jumping knight to 592. i like white yeah
i like white i mean vessel in is
doing some nice things here i mean on a
good day rook to d7 c5 it's not going to
be that easy for you to stop
the natural advancement i want to say of
white's pieces
c5 rook
d793 what's happening on wesley's side
of the board what yeah it's it's not
clear at all you're yeah that
night's night
yeah the night's not going anywhere
except maybe night to d4 knight to f4
now well honestly i want to play e5 e4
badly but like open the bishop you know
but fair does it go anywhere like
e493 to start with right e4 knight to e3
yeah
like probably not one pawn but quite a
few
no you you're supposed to be playing
on your side i've also
a client
yeah yeah yeah
rook d5 i like your rook d5 uh
we're seeing advantage
vessel in i mean he started
yesterday with three big donuts losses
absolutely was winning maybe slight
advantage but we know wesley is not
generally the type of player he's going
to be looking for a big fight with the
black pieces
especially he is content with the draw
but how do you get it does vaseline have
more than a slight push that's
my question
it looks like a very comfortable
advantage right i have rook d7 knight e3
and c5 is
three really good candidates when i go
rook to fso right
so if i go
let's say i play c5
and threaten rook d7
the c5 open the case for e4 maybe
right that is the thing yeah so at the
moment
c5 e4 e4 and then try to get the root
guy i don't play like that or like to
move
move
yeah
what's the move uh that we are playing
rook f8 also
so let's try to improve the position
somehow
i could also start with knight e6 now
that you don't have the pawn on
c5 maybe i can try to reroute the knight
there
there's no pin along the a to g diagonal
coming at least not yet
okay so i'm not
how do you build things up here yeah i'm
not a big fan of my bishop on e2 maybe
bishop to d3
um by the way the camera is right now on
nepo versus that bow is suffering and by
the way bishop f-8 was fate was played
which was not g5 i respect this move
because c4c5 was one of the moves i was
really anxious to get in so the move
bishop f8 to counter that and maybe also
play for but do you counter that right
now so
let's go bishop what if i go knight to
e3
no okay so if something was played i
think it's knight to e3 because 93 is
very logical of course the point being
that once you go rook f7
if you do which we did i go c5
so f6
yes that's ironic
allows knight d5 within them
allows us one thing but this is like
please i want you to play knight f5 why
would the knight be worse
place i think he's just saying that
you're trying to find a route for your
rooks to invade and once you put the
knight on d5 i just simply go rook to f7
now you no longer have the move c5
and once again that is the game okay
let's let's see between jan and
john's game because this is the thing
yeah that's a resonation mode i believe
it is coming and
it's done
wow that is just done wow
jordan van forres uh
wins
convincingly smoothly uh 20 about 28
moves with black
complete destruction uh yeah
uh
d5 d5 yeah so why stop playing should be
fine
the question remains yes yeah
don't look too much for me there for
those answers or unless you want to join
our pro subscription
and our uh boy that la that final
position is very visual it just looks so
terrible um
one of the one of the things a lot of
amateur players you know will come and
say what did i do wrong coach
and you know as insightful as i am i
will point to the rook on a1 and say
excuse me but you never included the
rook you never moved your queen what do
you mean what did you do wrong
i was following the game of nepo
ouch ouch uh
our congratulations by the way forward
to jordan a very very good day
wesley so uh topple off well we think
that's uh vessel in has the upper hand
uh
still a lot going on there and this is
the this is our extra pawn game
very much followed your advice uh
linear did i mean except for exchanging
the rook so magnus put his queen on h3
he put his pawn on a4
okay see
should i how hard slash easy it will be
to convert this one magnus if possible
at all
b4
uh
i
don't look now
i'm going to try to push
uh
push him baby as quickly as i can well i
was thinking at first like you think you
look at this h1 rook and you think okay
it's not joining anytime soon pathetic
but then
yeah okay as long as your queen is on h3
does nothing as well other than attack
h2 i'm fine with my rook on h1 yeah so
b4 b5 possibly queen b4 support opponent
and then let's go yeah and the nice part
is usually speaking whenever the queen
was to
give up its attack on h2 the rook
quickly
joins the fray as well this looks good
for magnus
versus
once again some some crazy stuff happens
this bishop
but let's stop ourselves and join zagreb
with uh alejandro and a special guest
hello and we're here with a great victor
with the black pieces against jan
nepogniachi jordan van forest you said
that you had two wins last tournament it
seems that you have two wins per day now
uh today i had only one but yeah i
cannot complain i mean today was an
exceptionally good day i think
i don't know why why it's going so well
but i guess everything is just clicking
for me and then sometimes i can play
some good chess i guess
very good choice i'm very entertaining
because your game against osiris was
just
looked like a bloodbath on the board
yeah yeah that was crazy i i guess i was
winning somewhere but
um also like the previous game was so
long i didn't have um
i wasn't as sharp i would say and then i
got very confused with all the things
going on at his rook like going from c3
to a3 and i just couldn't figure things
out quite uh correctly speaking of that
rook c3a3 i wanted to bring your
attention to a not so recent game a
certain pillsbury against alaska 1895
1896. did you know this game no you can
see this position on the board and the
cool thing was it was just yesterday
game rook c3 rook e3 yeah it's quite
amazing i mean um i i haven't seen this
game although maybe i have but it's just
such a long time ago like i must have
seen it when i was you when i was like
very small but other than that it
doesn't really ring a bell and yeah rook
a3 here i guess it's winning for black i
mean in the game fortunately it was not
winning for my opponent
at all the game was actually very
complicated it was a brilliancy by
alaska ended up making pillsbury on c5
very cool game i recommend you check it
out check it out
but let's check out the game there you
destroyed your opponent why you come up
with these great ideas rookie one such a
well-known position
and today you saw we saw bishop b5
bishop e2 against
we see this bishop e6 here where else
all this creativity coming from well i
mean in classical it's very hard to be
creative these days because your
opponent has a lot of time to think but
in these rapid games you're like you can
get away with a lot more things um
especially because the opponent just
doesn't have the time to refute the
dubious line so
um or like when they're black they
cannot find a way to make a draw all
that often so i mean here bishop e6 it's
it's a little bit dubious but i thought
maybe for this game it's gonna be
interesting
it seemed like it fell apart very
quickly for him where do you think it
started to go wrong yeah i was surprised
i i mean this knight eight three knight
c4 i didn't know but um
suddenly i just got a very pleasant
position and it just collapsed but i
cannot really pinpoint his his final
mistake i think he mentioned something
along the lines of queenie one somewhere
after me you can show it um
yeah i think he said c for you should go
queenie one here um but or queen
everyone i couldn't quite understand if
he meant queen of honor queenie one but
at least harry keeps everything together
but nonetheless with all my active piece
i should be much
better although i didn't think it was
that much better but i'm very
comfortable here with the black piece of
course and how long did it take you to
see this beautiful shot bishop takes you
to basically ending the game yeah i was
actually calculating it in a little bit
different line already um like if he
makes um instead of c4 if he plays
like let's say h3 or something yeah like
i i have this idea of already and then
after c4 is just basically provoking me
to to do this bishop to hg2 so i saw
immediately i was just calculating if
it's like working or if i'm plundering
something but i guess it's just
completely winning for black you made it
look easy and the conversion of course
from here quite simple
expectations coming into the tournament
now that we're halfway through the rapid
have they changed
no i have still zero expectations
actually um before this i had a very
tough period in classical chess so i'm
just happy to win some games again and
i'll just see how it goes but i'm very
happy for now absolutely a great
performance so far here for jordan guys
let's go back to the studio we have
plenty of games left in this round well
thank you very much again our
congratulations to uh jordan and if you
look at this game that he just won
against nepo you say what did he do
wrong
nothing
if that wasn't a flawless game i don't
know what you could call it and for a
rapid chase
you would be proud to play that well in
a classical game yeah and you know
this algorithm that checking your moves
right and after that and and some would
actually get if in this game imagine
this game played online and you checked
black always followed like first and
second
second right
yes
to blame that he didn't pose serious
problems perhaps exactly uh jumping into
the game of ali raza i think we have to
go to magnus guys oh magnus is
definitely on its last legs uh it does
feel like magnus is just pulling away
from his opponent
but now he's two a pawns ahead he took
on a4 yes instead of b4 he decided to
take on a4 but without that a pawn is
just going down the board
the problem is whenever you move the
queen off the h3 square i will have
enough time to move my rook off the h1
square and when you return to h3 i can
just simply go king to g1 exactly so
that frees up my rook anytime you move
the queen i can free up my rook
right
and once i free up my rook that's the
only resource that's not playing right
now in the position then my position is
just simply winning exactly
and we do have
h5
desperation mode well it's time to do
something the problem is whenever you go
h4 i go g4 i know i was about to say
your queen is myself self uh imprison uh
your own queen after h5 so no threat
with that move isn't queen b5 and uh a6
at that moment
very strong impression yes yeah well he
probably returns the queen queen e6 but
then i just get my rook out rook to c1
exactly i don't even worry about the a2
point if i manage to exchange the a to
pawn for your e5 i'll take that trade
any time of day absolutely absolutely
you will
uh with gusto glee
now queen to b5 just uh seems to be
killing the game right now exactly
and how are we doing on time
ten minutes from magnus and uh what is
that two minutes for linear linear
mm-hmm not
not looking good
by the way we just saw a really flat
effort a moment ago by magnus and uh
dare we mention it you know world
champions they do this all the time they
snap back
a very good victory should it occur i
mean it hasn't
it's not game over yet but defeating
lanier
is
yeah it's nice he he engaged in the
right strategy we know lanier is so well
prepared and especially in a rapid time
situation it's very difficult to come
back uh his uh his opening choices with
g3 avoid any sort of theoretical battle
i think this is what magnus wanted and
he got it and he was able to easily
outplay him after that right
in the game between wesley so
vessel and topolof and wesley so
doesn't feel like vessel in really has
done anything whatsoever to perturb
uh wesley who
again he's tied for first right
with ali raza
more or less he's improved his bishop
he's improved his knight heck he's even
improved his rook and we can imagine
that if we get in a couple of moves
ourselves knight d4 bishop c5 wesley
might be the one
saying who
stands better bishop c5 on the board
tickling f2 g3
uh things have
changed a lot here miro yeah a lot
actually what happens now knight e4 is
almost a must yeah and he did it and you
can put the bishop on b4 if you like and
he did it as well uh
very uh handsome squares uh
no problem who comes to a fate knight
might return to f4 again g3 on c5 yeah
g3 okay so f4 is under control exactly
yeah how about doubling on doubling
with the idea one day to go knight c5 i
know he goes a6 maybe even better like
trading the pawns going rook a2 if this
happens that's
even better scenario exactly no wesley
uh
somehow wesley has uh turned the tables
here and i feel uh
he is the one uh calling the shots again
let's just check in on magnus
queen e6 25 26 happened yeah we're
expecting rook c1 i think we will stay
with this one but we have another one
that's exploding right now and it is the
one between ali reza and mama diary
because my medieval just simply
blundered
he played queen to d3 after rook to b1
allowing this queen trade and
is he getting just all sorts of
checkmates afterward to b8 yeah b8 is
coming right right isn't that a game
over i mean i understand you go d2 and
you get a queen but you get checkmated
in the process now wait a second maybe
he goes rookie to check first that's
fine
king goes to the first rank and then d2
happens i have two
so but i don't go to the first show
no but now you can take and then d2 and
then you uh promote with a
check so no i don't know
yes king g1 oops excuse me i apologize
yeah king to g1 d2 i have to play knight
f2 and uh you'll be happy uh yes uh who
was promoting that the bishop and g8 is
a good idea the bishop on f8 yeah it's
also a good thesis yes uh to make me
careful about the eighth rank is the
whole point
but
that there is a tricky
move right can i play for two a
perpetual check somehow what perpetual
truck no i don't have a control rook
takes f8
yes i apologize no perpetual chair never
but see
your move you're as good as anybody else
in this position because there is no
move
i could lose with the best of them
uh rook a2 um
somehow i don't like just capturing and
capturing so
let's just
yeah you probably do this and you can
you still have to deal with the back
rank weaknesses don't you
it feels like alireza
is winning
completely win completely winning sorry
completely winning all right
uh this is pretty much game over uh mom
of the year will need a miracle well he
got one in the game against apollo today
so he will need another one to save this
one and he got one on the first day
against sarri
game yes he's getting a lot of miracles
he is he is uh for sure but let's move
back to magnus because
dominguez is down to his last 40 seconds
i believe on his clock with pretty much
pre that position at this point
rook c6
rook c6
queen to f5
do i pick up another one probably not
i'm i'm sure i so want to play the move
f4 here but uh
you can actually take it it's not like
the there's a pin
along the he played it he did player
okay you're on a top four no no i just
like uh
i feel that uh
but that position is just simply uh a
technical win yeah
very quickly magnus was like
gif me that guy yeah but wait a second
right and then uh h2 you have to read
yeah that's that's the thing that's the
tickle i'm intrigued that's the tickle
he's done
okay do we dance to d2 do we take on h4
i think that they go right you're right
i can't or maybe king
e1
inviting queen h2 and then
or you can take twice on g3 in either
case i'm trying to find that there is
some queen h1 queen c6 thing if you
go specifically kingy one very true
and we're being told that
that queen e5 was
five is a blunder
wow but the move that was winning i mean
if this is the only move that was
winning rook takes g6 check come on come
on i see how misleading this compute
evaluation sometime is
like we are saying like
everything is over right
basically misleading people because for
this game to be over like a simple check
on e5 which
everybody everybody plays tempo we've
seen magnus was ten minutes and he is
still the world champion and he played
it without hesitation and he spoils the
win that's crazy
by the way we do have a result wesley so
our tournament leader a co-leader has
drawn as black against vessel and
topolof topolof bouncing back from a
disastrous start
but
i it helped me did vessel and
draw all of his games today
i mean he's drawing he drew two he drew
the
first one against apollo against mommy
the arrow right
and then with the black pieces
let me help me out let me help you out
yes he did draw against dominguez and so
three draws through
three losses three drawings he lost his
three draws
all right isn't some sort of a pattern
so that
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can expect three
victories yeah well another pattern is
that magnus is just not himself up to
this point
uh we remember also his game against
apollo in the first round
despite the fact that sure he won that
game he didn't win it smoothly no and he
got his usual type of position grinding
position
and then he lost the advantage allowed
his opponent back into the game we're
seeing a pattern right now repeating
against dominguez as well and he had
such a huge time advantage
this is what surprises me uh the most
about this game okay
but
the current position uh magnus let's say
blew it with the move queen e5 fine
what should he do
rook c7 a christian and just say okay go
ahead eat my pawns and i will go king
e1 to d2 yes probably rook to c7 yeah
rook to c7 is is a good move probably uh
the most testing move in the position
and how do we assess the position
because
quite frankly queen takes h2 so you take
on h2 you take on g3 and now you try to
defend the f7 pawn either with king to
g8 probably with king to g8
um
it's uh
i don't know miro uh
is it is it
it's gonna be a race
you're gonna go h3 uh three results it's
a three results game
i don't think it's three results because
if white wants a draw he can make it
wrong
how does white make a draw force a draw
uh after
say king g8 i don't know rook f8
i mean
rook f8 uh
yeah speaking of missed opportunities i
think furuja played the move which kind
of gives away all the advantage really
yes
h1 for whatever reason not to g1 but to
h1 and now at least according to my not
very strong engine
on my screen h5 the move that i was
trying to make where it actually works
uh
okay that's the magnus game so eight
wow i mean h5 and okay and mamadyarov
plays knight d6 after which
that should be
that should be all she were rook takes
and i know you take one on g7 i mean
it's still it's still
complicated crazy magnus magnus game
yeah let's
switch to magnus's game but just keep in
mind the other one is also very very
entertaining absolutely they have by the
way
transposed instead of rook c7 at once
king e1 at once was magnus's choice but
they have
transposed to the position that we
thought
was the most
challenging uh really realistic
and again um
this looks like a funky race i can go
queen f6 a forced rook f8 i can i can
get my pawn to a6 you're going to get
your panda
h3 can i just look at this
let's say i go queen of six queen f6
there's also this silly check from e3
right after you go queen f6
i'm probably forced to go queen f8 first
or rook cafe yeah rook f8 sorry yeah
it's h6 a6
h3
and after a7
let's say here i'm giving you a check
yeah so that your uh
you're in time right um
i don't know
king d1 h28 queen no no no no you you
you can promote because you're
controlling the h1 good good good 8th
queen
wow oh he just played queen takes d4
was he trying to join the pawn grubbers
association
not in a good moment
because now the h pawn is actually
running and he did it very quickly i did
lanier h3 well he has to because he has
15 seconds on his clock
you mean play quickly very quickly
same move
okay so this is inviting queen f6 and
now you have no queen e3
and you have to play rook
to f8 by the way but that looks
very good for white sorry please yeah
ferruja is winning i mean completely
it's it's it's shifted to one more time
yeah and now it's that this checkmating
pattern is is really uh doing good stuff
it's important and i will show you the
difference between king g1 and king h1
after it's just ridiculous yeah there's
a lot of beautiful motifs there
let's stay with this one for the moment
okay so age
and
again they're they're
i think magnus is really struggling with
this one because
uh
queen f6
threatening nate
will force rook f8 right and then
this race
uh he's getting worried about this race
uh and he might start with a move like
well he did queen e4 attacks the rook
and car was h1 just in case no don't
think about taking my pawn i have queen
e8 so rook
anyway very quickly
and once more you start to look at a6
right
a6 a7 and this queen
is ideal
and maybe we're going to see
the rook will come back also to the
first rank too a6 h2 a7
a1 h1
you take on h1 i take one f4 i pick up
your rook and then we get three versus
two in a queen's end game no i don't
like that so i'm thinking after rook f8
uh a6 h2 rook c1
wait you don't like that with white or
with black with white really h2 yeah i
don't i i like i have an extra pawn
though a very strong extra pawn on the a
file i'm expecting magnus to play the
move rook c1
just to take away
that one more
is what you're saying but what if i go
queen to g1 now you don't have a7
anymore okay so it's kind of a mutual
standoff there queen g1 queen e3
uh then i can take on c1 yeah oh you
take on c1 you're in trouble no no i i
have to queen h1 yeah
queen g1 well
um
here's the moment i mean he could play
a7 and allow the loss of the f4 pawn
and magnus is down to his last 30
seconds as well whoa whoa whoa whoa
and he's done it he's played a7 allowing
allowing that's the practical choice
guys you think so yes i mean three
versus two with the queens on the board
is is going to be very difficult for the
defender i think
well white's king is going to be exposed
in this queen ending too it's not five
seconds for linear he has to make a move
and he's done it what you said
queen
queen of
apparently
okay
right
yeah what what do we do or yeah
yeah
you want king d1 makes the most sense
again how much time does
yeah it's seconds literally seconds like
20 seconds versus 20 seconds wow okay so
we got to take the rook so you can think
of this oh absolutely by the way queen
a4 fortune why don't you take the rook
ah yeah right we are not forced to
unlock it from the promotion right yeah
so now you have what you have oh my
goodness we have another check
you have to take that rook at some point
right you cannot leave the rook hanging
well
i mean i don't have to take the a pawn
though
i can just play queen takes a2
yeah no but then leaving the a7 pawn
like that i think that's a worse version
for you queen a5 check okay there is
nothing wrong with queen of what king of
one right then i have a queen f5 check
or queen f3 i see
yeah so finally i'll escape f1 is on the
board right or whatever it is
wait a second can he take and the moment
white promotes he's done it yeah the
moment white promotes can he go for
queen c1 isn't it an improvement yeah he
actually does it right enough move order
yeah
and now back to c5
you can never go to the
you know
diagonals right you can't go to king g2
first yeah you have very limited options
of escaping those those checks so
e3 that's queen c2
but okay e3 queen c2 king g3
oh that's when you go queen c7 check
yeah
i'm actually not picking up the queen
without taking the queen is a kind of a
funny moment look he's done it
i tell you with no time on their clock
both players are coming up with some
devilishly
great
moves they're good aren't they
we're having some
lack problems right now unfortunately we
apologize for that and by the way uh
crazy things are still happening in fa
rouge's game i don't understand
anything i feel like at some point it
was to say plus 50 for ferruja i don't
know whatever it means and now it's it
says equal and possibly
you know
zero zero or something
what the heck i thought uh
we were saying miracles how many
miracles can the shack
possibly cash in
what i'm no longer sure if he's not
gonna win yeah because it's such a sharp
game
this game might win this one was mated
on h.a ten moves ago that's the same
king that had to be checkmated on h8
absolutely right
down to his last eight seconds oh my
gosh this is where you just
hate yourself like you have to make a
move
through two seconds on the clock two
seconds
oh my gosh
so how many miracles has uh
shaq received so far in this tournament
a couple right at least a couple up to
this point wow we might be seeing the
third one
can i have another
rook check what's better than two year
goals three
and this is a full point miracle if you
imagine no this is he manages to win
yeah if he manages to and by the way
this is another incredibly tricky move
this move knight d6
okay all right i see that's not coming
to c4 wait a second what what what what
takes d5 king e2 not what i'm not really
sure what he's looking for
[Music]
wow magnus is not happy
wow and something crazy is going on in
this game
well i think we're going to see a draw
to say as
so uncharacteristic of magnus not
winning such positions right and
how do you explain ali
ali reza's king why can't exactly at all
it's a draw you can't take on f3 and
then h4 yeah you can right now you can
take on f3 and then h4 yes but that's
what i think you probably don't need to
right
i think he's playing for a win i think
shaq is playing for a win
does he have objective reasons to do so
i i don't think so well
uh on the other hand with the a pawn
episode you can't really risk anything
right the a pawn but shack like king d3
i'm not trying to
still be looking for ways to like save
you know well this knight on the e3 is
fantastic because g4 f5 are both
prevented
let's start with the obvious there
uh the knight on e3 is good but
okay so now i have to go h4 h4 i think
just makes a draw right yeah it feels
again guys i don't think he's going for
a truck
i think shaq wants more
how do you get more here who was it i
think it was levon who uh came after
this type of miracles and he was like i
got used to uh draw miracles
i want full point miracles right
right this is what maybe mamadiarov is
looking for one of the things that makes
these players so extraordinary
is their ability to
change their perspective from
i'm fighting fighting fighting to a draw
oh now i'm going to play for a win yeah
and i remember very very well i was in
prague
um gary kasparov had challenged the
entire czech olympic team
he would play the czech olympic team
simultaneously and the event occurred
over a few days
and in one of the matches he was getting
killed
absolutely absolutely getting killed
and then miracle of miracles he had an
opportunity he saved the match he made a
draw
and he said to me immediately after
dinner
i i think i had a winning chance
you know and i was like gary
you should be grateful you're gonna be
so grateful
yeah but i had a chance to win you're
right but i had a chance to win six
seconds for mama diarrhoea
i actually don't like what he's doing
what is that
was that a good no no no
no no no no no d4
can't i queen on h8 i think you're
quitting first yes yeah you just knight
takes d4 and h4 what is this well you
can definitely go king d5 and h5 king e6
but then king f3 king is in the square
and those pawns they are indirectly
protecting each other he's winning he's
lost he's lost knight d4 just 94 wins
this is a willie
he's done it
f5 i don't think that one
no i know it's the right one yeah
because there's king support in it
that was a close miracle
now this was a game that was checkmate
can how how did he
escape this checkmate because it was
such a beauty
right here we left it yeah so after that
h1 after knight d6
came knight takes g7 and what is this my
d6 by the way is a mistake
i believe you yeah yeah but then the
idea was if you take the knight i guess
it's night h6 is that the idea six maybe
or knight f6 nice f6 i like more yeah so
you know i don't know for whatever
reason
that's a nice check mate okay so it
looks like it's game over he plays
knight beef b5 which is a bad move by
the way okay
do you need
okay
ah you're saying ah like you understand
what i have h5 who understands what's
happening in this position because it's
knight f5 he could have taken and taken
on
take him with check and taken on f8
right but he didn't do this
what
f7 is the only myth not to get
checkmated because king g6 knight h4
have you ever checkmated somebody with
knight h4 move yes i don't think so
maybe with black but certainly not with
white yeah
and it was still winning here right this
was the double so knight h2 was terrible
and what was the what was the solution
side of knight e4 check
yeah right
e4 such an obvious move right
knight h2 and
crazy crazy crazy and it was almost a
miracle that was not to be
um
wow
how many decisive games was that in this
round by the way there was two i believe
only two yeah only at the end but
thanks to his victory that means my
horse pulls ahead
alireza as uh wesley sowe could only
draw
and uh alireza won a standard
so look
who's on top after six rounds in a way
yeah not much has changed at the very
top right it's ali reza firuja leading
with nine points overall with two draws
and the win against one giraffe today
wesley saw and jordan one forest are
trailing one point each our leaders all
did the same thing too
all of them magnus carlsen fell behind
excuse me
jordan uh
doing incredibly violent mvl3 draws not
what we expect from mag uh from mdl but
there was magnus
and let's jump to zagreb
firstly we gotta check the picks
you uh be happy about that
uh welcome hero oh yeah well
that's brilliant yeah
[Laughter]
it's okay we're just warming up
let's jump to zagreb for some final
thoughts of yet another eventful round
with anastasia and alejandro
guys what a round that we had here to
finish the day for me personally the
story of the days was the same as
yesterday alireza leads but magnus
carlsen makes the headlines what a
terrible day he had of day of chess
today exactly he made only one point out
of three right and losing this game
against mahmud it's not often that he
also loses on time
so it's really difficult to see him in
such a situation i think he's still
emotional i think this was a really big
blow yesterday he made for himself so
what do you think
i think he'll need to bounce back i mean
he's the best one at that to pick
himself up after a bad day win a bunch
of them in a row to try to catch up with
the leaders but right now rapids count
for double and that means there's a bit
of a difference between alireza's score
and magnus's there's a lot of catch up
to be done and only one day of rapid
left yeah and jordan showed a very good
result to them in all his games i mean
he had the advantage and actually
won the last one such an impressive
score today and also i i would like
actually to mention that we have a
birthday today yes we have
the general director of uh grand chester
has birthday and um we are
congratulating him all of us and to wish
him all the best of course and
that's also was a good news for today
absolutely happy birthday michael well
that was a great day of chess for us
loved commentating on it guys back to
you that was a great day and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you both an
interesting perspective that might that
magnus steals the headlines again
alireza's doing great but magnus's score
yeah that was something uh christian all
right
no for me it was and i highlighted this
at the beginning of the show it it it
was the day for the young guns that is
ali reza and jordan these are the
players that right now are impressing me
uh the most ali reza maybe some hiccups
along the way but he got the job done
against mamedyarov in the last one and
jordan just impressive preparation all
together he could have even scored more
and potentially caught up with ali reza
if he would have won that game against
ivan sturridge so definitely these are
the two players that i'm having my eyes
on right now still a lot of games to
play a lot of rapid tomorrow three more
rounds and then 18 rounds of blitz to
come so a lot of chess to be played
still absolutely christian did he just
say 80
18.
very nice
well uh thank you very much for joining
us for today's round we certainly
enjoyed our presentation and tomorrow
we'll do it all again as uh same time
same channel three games of rapid uh
coming up on day three miro is one
wonderful my pleasure yeah thank you
very much and see you tomorrow guys
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited